foreign
all right good morning everybody
thanks for your patience I think I'm a
little bit Rusty
and welcome to Transportation
um I still consider it the best
Committee in the house I don't know if
you will concur
um just to get started on the later side
um for all our new members my name is
representative Thomas Welsh from
Hooksett and Dunbarton and I'll
introduce the vice chair okay we'll go
ahead
my name is representative Ted Gorski and
I represent
Bedford
and our Clerk
my name is representative Carol Crawford
and I represent moultonborough Tamworth
and Madison
and our ranking member
I'm representative George Sykes I
represent city of lebanon's Ward 2.
foreign
thank you if we can just start on one
end and go around if you want to
introduce yourselves and where you're
from
representative Matt Coker I represent
Meredith
thank you
representative Charlie Sinclair Laconia
District Five
representative Charles Foote Derry
yep
um representative valuency of Merrimack
County 20 District 26 which is Loudon
Canterbury
Bosque and Danbury and over Hill
Salisbury and Webster God bless you
foreign
representative Dan vayu I representative
Amherst
representative Casper Rambo from Bedford
representative Drew Fox I'm from Keene
ward 3 Cheshire District 2.
I'm representative John Sellers from
Bristol I represent Bristol Alexandria
Bridgewater Heber and Groton Dorchester
orange Grafton Kanan and Enfield
I'm Kathy Staub I'm from Ward 5 in
Manchester which is Hillsboro District
25.
I'm Phillip Jones representing Ward 5 in
Manchester
and excuse me in Keen I didn't want her
seat
I'm sorry
when I say the best Committee in the
house that's what I refer to we have
serious work to do here but there's
always time for some laughter we do try
to keep it light uh we do have a busy
morning I've got quite a few of the
Departments that were gracious enough to
come here with a presentation this
morning
uh but I do have just a couple of quick
things and on an outline that I'll run
over
um and also this afternoon I I picked
five bills and I gave them ample time so
I'm just going to run through this if
there's any other questions we'll have
more than enough time and opportunities
later in the day
um and I'm not going to go through all
of this uh just recommendations greeting
and ground rules uh all of you I don't
know if you've done it yet but a single
email for legislative business is
recommended uh the the the the the state
the legislative services will help you
set one up if you need it uh we do keep
it light here dressing decorum we we are
still doing the people's business and so
we do ask about all the committee
members um you know dress in business
what is the proper term for that
business attire business well business
professional there's a term for it in
other words
respectful
um and even though we do keep things
late here we do have to follow some
decorum uh and structure otherwise it
would be a free-for-all I'll get into
that in a little bit uh General ground
rules uh please no food no coffee
um if you do want to bring water in
that's fine I try to keep mine on the
floor I ask everybody to do the same it
just looks better especially now that
we're on Zoom uh that our table doesn't
look like a bar
um
obviously no food during public hearings
either
anybody with any medical issues just
notify me on the side if there's any
special things I need to do for you
uh one touchy one and we keep going back
and forth on this is the use of
electronic devices
I've got mine here today
um
but our house has gone back and forth on
this in terms of rules at one point we
weren't allowed to have them at all when
we're having public hearings
we're supposed to be giving the people
testifying before us our utmost
attention and it doesn't look good when
you've got things turned up and
everybody and you're blocking the view
of the person testifying however since
then they they do come in handy if you
use a rate because you can seek a lot of
information while even during a hearing
so
I'm not going to say well you can't have
them on the table at this point let's
use common sense for now and we'll see
how it goes uh but but I ask when people
are testifying that's what they're here
for and it's our job and our duty to
give them our attention
um so you all know I don't know if
you've seen yet there is in the office a
set of cabinets you all will have an
assigned drawer pretty good size for
anything you need to keep their
paperwork and such
um we do well I don't need to mention
that one
um fire alarm exits Etc we do have
charts in the office and in the hallway
we can go over those on a one by one
basis if you if you need to see them
um
okay
bear with me here I am a little bit
Rusty myself
our committee in general partisan
balance well interestingly enough first
time I've seen it this is actually my
sixth term on this committee but we are
10 10. even all the Committees with the
exception of rules I believe is an even
split this year
um today committee seating I did assign
these seats for today
I don't think there were any issues but
I may make an adjustment uh or two
before next meeting
um but but it is my My Prerogative uh
and it was the speaker this year that's
that asked for mixed seating I did the
best I could mixing it but when you've
got a few in the front that kind of
takes the uh takes the ability to go
even uh you know every other impossible
uh
uh typical build topics I'll touch on
this one for a second because there's a
lot of confusion
um
transportation we we deal with motor
vehicle law
for the most part A lot of people still
think that we deal with the monies and
funding that's actually Public Works so
on Lake Washington for example we
discuss specialize in just the the the
motor vehicle law itself not the money
and not the maintenance of our roads
um
second committee work that's what early
bills by the way we do have seven early
bills this week uh this year
so for an example if it if it deals with
some monies
we will vote on it and if it's a
positive motion and it succeeds then
it'll go to say uh Finance for example
so we do have seven bills that are going
to require the attention of two
committees
I'm sure you've all seen between the
orientations the calendar watch for
notices
um the deadline for me to get everything
in the schedule or in the calendar is
Wednesdays
Tuesdays is our day and so I will try to
keep everything on Tuesdays
but always keep an eye on the calendar
weekly just to make sure things things
don't change
and I think
I'll go over the public hearing and
executive session I believe we've got
some time afterwards before we get into
the public hearing that I've scheduled
this afternoon because I know we do have
a lot of people that would like to do
their introductions and so I've called
in today the the faces that you will
most usually see in transportation we've
got Department of Motor Vehicles
Department of Safety Department of
Transportation I believe they were
invited I don't see them yet but Marine
Patrol and we have who else is coming
what else did I say
fish and game I did invite them as well
we do every now and then get their input
on ohrv bills
uh and I do have a couple of surprise
guests if we have time for introductions
afterwards so uh with that being said
I'm going to turn it over to director
marasco from the Department of Motor
Vehicles
any questions from the committee
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman director marasco
can you make this slide presentation
available to us
okay
because it's got a lot of dense material
in there and it would be nice to have it
as a reference
yeah and actually I have to say
something too I did see somebody come in
the room for anybody watching online I
do apologize and I'll take the hit I did
make sure the room was set up for uh
with a microphone for a PowerPoint
presentation but there was no
legislative activity going on it was
merely an introduction by the department
to our new members any other questions
from the committee representative Jones
excuse me representative Jones if you
could answer the question on the
microphone that'd be great too thank you
it's very simple
um others um because of our econ
economic problems a lot of it is being
blamed on lack of truck drivers uh being
out there and many states are facility
facilitating the CDL process I know you
talked about the mobile earlier and that
sounds very good but is there anything
else that
New Hampshire is doing to facilitate
getting a CDL license
question uh representative Jones thank
you there are many things that are going
on on the cdlfront expansion is one of
them to make it more convenient
geographically throughout the state to
allow people to get there take their CDL
exam the mobile vehicle is going to be
very good having um a full eight CDL
examiners to do the testing is going to
be very important the other thing that
that is being rolled out nationally and
is a credit to administrator Jeff
oberdank is a a new testing model for
CDL that makes it more seamless a
modernization model and New Hampshire
was uh leading the way on that thanks to
Jeff's hard work so that also is is
going to uh to benefit the CDL Community
the other thing is we're working with
Bob Scully we have regular meetings with
Bob and nhmta to figure out how we could
be doing better for industry and I think
that is there anything I'm missing on
the CDL front Beyond those items Jeff
yeah I would just uh what I would say
and I belong in a number of national
committees with Amber one of the things
that we talk about we get on the calls
is that New Hampshire is a pretty rare
bird when it comes to CDL some states
have up to six months wait time for a
CDL test
I mean imagine if your company is is
needing drivers it's made it a place we
we know for a fact that other companies
are registering their vehicles and
moving some of their operations here
because of our CDL operation you can
take the test and you can you can take
the knowledge test and when after the
the nationally mandated 10-day waiting
period you can get a test on day 11.
that is unheard of nationally
thank you any other questions from the
committee
thank you again very much
uh
this Leicester Department of Safety to
come on up next
does anybody else have PowerPoints or
was it just a DMV
you do to it as well
[Laughter]
good morning Mr chairperson members of
the committee for those of you who don't
know me I'm Lieutenant Jay O'Leary I'm
the commander at Troop G
um it's nice to see some of the faces or
all the faces from last session please
don't hold my last session against me as
it was my first one I am going to Breeze
through just a quick overview of what
our troop does I think it's important
because we we will be working together
along with industry leaders that you'll
see that'll testify and essentially a
lot of the hospitals you'll be voting on
this session uh will be the one that'll
be enforcing them so I just want to kind
of give you some oversight and introduce
you to some of our subject matter
experts that will be providing testimony
I don't consider myself one of them but
so we are headquartered here in Concord
and to talk about the relationship that
we have with DMV very briefly we're
actually located in the DMV itself on
the first floor here in Concord
everything that we do for the most part
outside of our Federal Motor Carrier
enforcement directly relates to
something that's occurring at the DMV
whether it be through enforcement of the
dealer inspection rules or through
driver education or Pupil Transportation
essentially we're going where the the
legal arm of those type types of
programs the DMV programs we are
separated into four two two main
sections which is commercial Motor
Vehicle Enforcement one side and the
other one is known as field enforcement
and field enforcement like I said talk
is the dealership and inspection
stations mechanics things like that so
within that we have a couple other sub
units which are the DMV task force which
oversees our Pupil Transportation and
driver education programs and lastly we
have an investigations unit and they
have a pretty um pretty tough job
because they're the ones that are
looking at all the fraud that's
occurring at the DMV level so you can
imagine securing identities securing
titles or any of the documents that have
to that come in through the DMV that's
all that our investigations group does
so that's a big task for them as well
what makes us different is our
day-to-day job is essentially dealing
with that type of oversight so we cover
the entire State unlike a regional troop
where they they were essentially a
patrol function in that area our primary
role isn't a patrol function except for
commercial Motor Vehicle Enforcement
outside of that we are uh outside out
doing Audits and things like that and
investigations having to do with
dealerships and inspection stations so
that's our day-to-day in addition we
work very closely with all the same type
of Industry leaders that director
marasco spoke of we work closely with
nhada and members of the trans motor
transport Association and why that's
important is you know the goal would be
that we're having those conversations
with those industry leaders prior to
sitting down here testifying before you
so that we're all on the same page and
hopefully coming together and trying to
meet a resolution in whatever area that
we're looking to improve I'm going to
let staff sergeant come and speak to the
field enforcement as that's the group
that he oversees
hi good morning my name is staff
sergeant Tom Coleman I've been with The
Troop G for just under a year now but
State Police almost 17 years and so my
area of responsibility falls to the
field enforcement unit as well as the
DMV task for which Lieutenant already
mention is people Transportation driver
education as well as the investigations
unit so our field enforcement unit
really the monitoring audit uh
approximately 4 200 vehicle dealerships
and inspection stations to ensure
compliance with all the administrative
rules so what this means is our Troopers
and our AEI which are automotive
equipment inspectors are with industry
every single day we're out in the field
at these dealerships in these locations
conducting these audits working closely
hand in hand
uh we also do the opening and closing of
all the vehicle dealers and inspection
stations and we support the safety
mechanic certification program so our
aeis and our Troopers go out and
actually run the certification tests for
those mechanics
well we also do habitual offender
hearing notifications our Troopers go
out and once a person who's been deemed
habitual offender they need to be served
paperwork we do that function as well
this is on top of all the normal State
Police duties that are enforcing the
criminal Motor Vehicle Laws of the state
so I already spoke about these uh folks
briefly our aeis they're all skilled
mechanics they'll come to us work at
Troop G they have a lot of knowledge and
experience in automotive industry uh
they are responsible for the vast
majority of the compliance audits
um they can conduct reviews of the
dealer and inspection station locations
provide opening and they do field
testing mechanics
they also do which takes a lot of their
time as a salvage process when a vehicle
has been deemed a total loss by the
insurance companies these individuals go
out and uh
inspect the vehicle to make sure it's it
could be put back on the roads of New
Hampshire
so in part of the field enforcement unit
is also our Troopers uh pretty much all
the same duties as uh the aeis but a lot
of the times when these audits turn
criminal or conduct let's say the DMV
turns criminal they come to Troopers to
handle the investigative excuse me
investigative side of that investigation
or the enforcement inside of that
investigation
investigations unit uh station right
here in Concord at the at Troop G
barracks uh right now there's detective
sergeant and we have two investigators
we have three when they're fully staffed
they attach to investigating title fraud
uh vehicle theft and internal division
motor vehicle uh investigations license
registration fraud and identity theft
identity theft really being a key
um part of all this because we want to
ensure that the credentials we're giving
are residents of the state they're going
to the right people
so next up I'd like to introduce you
briefly is Trooper first class Rick
Dupont he oversees our driver education
section
thank you
and he'll probably be providing
testimony this session
but I can point Her Off on
lucky me
I did have the opportunity to testify in
2021 but
so I
my name is Trooper Rick Dupont I have
been coming up a trooper coming up on
almost 19 years and for most of that
time I have been stationed at the
Division of Motor Vehicles doing the
various functions that staff sergeant
Colin was speaking about either car
dealerships inspection stations the
investigations unit and for almost three
years now I've been the supervisor of
New Hampshire's driver's education
program
and it's a lot of work but uh we
we my office provides oversight and
support to secondary high schools
throughout the state
we have approximately 67 commercial
driver education schools and four of
those schools are actually run by high
schools
I think years ago there was there was
several more but there are only four
currently in the state of New Hampshire
we have approximately 160 active driver
education instructors that number is
changing almost monthly when people
retire or they become instructors
and I'm not bashful about asking people
if they want to become a driver
education instructor because we can
always use more
each of our instructors must uh
successfully complete the nine credit
driver education instructor curriculum
that is offered through Keene State
College and I'd like to also say through
White Mountains Community College up in
the Littleton Berlin area they've really
picked up the torch and have run with it
so White Mountains Community College
should get some mention there they also
provide instruction for the Vermont
instructors as well so for their program
um
so we the unit also completes driver's
education documents for the for new
students we conduct Administrative
Hearings if we find that a school or an
instructor is not remaining in
compliance with the 30 3100 rules and we
also conduct bi-annual compliance audits
or driver license schools we try and hit
half of the schools uh every other year
to make sure that they're staying in
compliance and for the most part I mean
I'd say like 99 percent of the schools
are staying within compliance
the driver education curriculum is one
of the things that we oversee
instructor
recertification and renewal of our
instructors as I said we have
approximately 160 of them
we each of our instructors after they
they're they're either college educated
or they are Department of Education
approved with their life experience so
our educators are really
high level Educators in the profession
they also have to take professional
development and have to have 51 hours
every three years just like a teacher
would have to have some professional
development our driver and instructors
also are following that requirement and
my office actually oversees the the
approval process for the
um
for that um development
next up is Trooper first class Greg
Hildreth uh Trooper first class class
Hildreth oversees our Pupil
Transportation unit and suspect he'll
probably be in here this session as well
warning members of the committee my name
is Trooper first class Gregory Hildreth
uh some of you may remember me from
prior testimony uh I've been with the
division of State Police 17 years I've
been doing people transportation for
about four years I oversee uh
basically I'll give you a quick rundown
on I'm also going to leave my business
card with you guys just so if you have
any follow-up questions you're welcome
to reach out to me uh but there are
about 130 school bus companies in the
state of New Hampshire right now uh the
changes monthly uh some come in some
decide to close the doors uh but that's
about the number of companies those
range from large companies like first
students stas Durham school Services I'm
sure you've all seen those and then you
get your smaller companies that you
might not be familiar with uh that might
only run one vehicle a vehicle so
um my unit is responsible for making
sure that those people driving those
buses uh right now we're anywhere
between 3000 and 3 500 we're closer to
3200 right now for this year as far as
drivers go but we need to conduct a
background checks per law to making sure
that these drivers are qualified to
actually drive
we also regulate and check on school bus
accidents uh there's a regulation in the
rules on the scfc 1300s that require any
school bus accident regardless of how
significant or minor to be reported to
my office within 24 hours
from there we decide which ones need
follow-up which ones have been compared
patterns you know multiple drivers
involved in so you know a couple fender
benders multiple times might be
indicative of we need to look at this
driver is it still capable safely
driving kids
um
another big part of this uh job is we
work very closely with federal agencies
as well as Homeland Security emergency
management hsem
for preparing for possible issues with
the nuclear power plant and Seabrook and
allocation of school buses we are one
tiny piece of a big puzzle of how do we
handle you know if there's a
radiological release at that power
station my job in my office is to
allocate buses and drivers for Mass
evacuation of certain towns or areas
depending on the windage we conduct four
quarterly drills building up to one
federally graded drill every year and
that actually
we're going to be having a drill I think
that's in April is the next one but one
of my big pushes in my department is
actually getting school bus drivers to
be knowledgeable and understanding of
what we're going to be asking them to do
in those situations so it's not
a lot of we take a lot of the myths out
of that to make sure we have drivers
that actually show up
another part of my job is audits uh we
actually follow up it's in the role to
follow up on actually checking the
equipment of the buses so uh we can do
this multiple ways through random audit
where we just go to a location and go
and check a specific number of random
buses selected out of uh the fleet and
we check the equipment on board make
sure it's serviceable make sure there's
no problems uh from tires to air brakes
if they have them hydraulic brakes the
equipment on board Medical Kit body
fluid spill kits we just make sure that
they are meeting the criteria we also
audit the driver files for every single
school bus driver in the state of New
Hampshire there must be a driver file
maintained at the principal location of
business and that ensures when I open
that up that I can find that they yep
they are background checked if they
require drug testing that that has been
done that they have the proper amount of
training hours annually it just gives me
a quick preview to make sure this driver
is in compliance and they belong on the
road
thank you sir
staff sergeant Huddleston oversees our
Motor Carrier unit he was not able to be
here today so uh Sergeant Scott Atherton
drew the Short Straw
good morning chairman in the committee
welcome
fitted in here uh my name is Sergeant
and I've been with um department of
safety for 21 years
I've been assigned essentially to
um
the The Troop G job that we've been
doing it used to be under the DMV as
motor vehicle inspectors and then
Highway Patrol so I've been lucky enough
to have been through all the positions
here and I've been assigned to motor
Care Unit probably for the last 15 years
um I also oversee the DMV task force
which is people transportation driver's
ed and uh CDL we have CDL task force too
where we assist the DMV with CDL testing
um
they do that five days a week the DMV
and we have a trooper that's available
and around those sites
every day of the week and if need be we
will assist them with testing also
we also do off-site testing so if
carriers or companies
want to pay for a detail we'll send a
troop route to them and they can do to
answer your question that'll help get
some CDL Drivers we've done a lot of
that in the past where we will go out
and do five or six tests for them during
the day uh or on the weekends and they
don't have to pull a truck out of
service to come down here to Concord and
whatnot so that's that's been a benefit
in this industry as well
um the mode of care enforcement unit we
will oversee all the federal laws FMCSA
Federal Motor Carrier Administration
um they have an office right here in
Concord we work hand in hand with them
through grants and funding to try and
get extra money to get extra patrols out
there to enforce motor carer stops in
and try and keep trash reductions down
with those as well we have
just under 30 Troopers trained
through the Federal Motor Carrier to do
these inspections on these trucks
um
we we have the capability of placing
drivers and vehicles out of service we
also are the only ones in the state that
can stop these trucks without any
articulable suspicion or probable cause
we can just stop them to do a routine
inspection
um we also have those multiple
um Troopers trained in doing weight
enforcement uh where they assigned
portable scale so they can they can pull
those out and they're they're less than
an inch thick and they can slide those
underneath the tires of these trucks and
do weights roadside we also have semi
Portables that
um I think we have three or four of
those that will set up at different
locations throughout the state where we
can pull multiple trucks over those
during the day and save a little bit of
time with that as well as our fixed
scales that we have down at Windham on
both the North and southbound side
um
we're trying to get some what they call
weigh in motion scales that we can put
we've been working with DOT to try and
get these that we can put into the
pavement and Troopers that can be nearby
can get a rough readout if a truck may
be overloaded that way not wasting the
truck's time for stopping them and
weighing them when they're not
overweight and the trooper's time wait
because we do we'll wait trucks and they
won't always be overweight we just try
and judge them so hopefully that's
something coming down the road that
we'll be able to offer to the state and
it'll save some time for industry as
well we also assist
um other agencies our Troopers with
crashes involving commercial Motor
Vehicles so if a local Town gets a bus
crash or a truck crash a lot of times
they'll reach out to Troop G For
assistance with those
um and we will go out and take care of
the motive motor care inspection side of
that so they don't have to deal with
that
I think I covered most of that
so there's three different weight
enforcement laws that we um
we enforce obviously the highway the
interstate highway systems we 93 89 95
there's a certain law for that it's a
flat fee out there for those and then we
do the non-interstate roads Route 3 104
all the non-interstates and those those
side roads and non-interestate roads are
two cents a pound so the fines can be a
little more steeper on those roads
compared to the highway and also the
additional weight so a lot of these
trucking companies can register for
additional weights uh which will make
them haul they'll build a hall heavier
um and we have more of a leeway there
with um their weights but if they're not
certified we'll go back to the
non-interstate and the interstate laws
so
that's what we do with that we also have
a new entrant
group I think we have three true one
full-time and two auxiliary Troopers
assigned to that
they're responsible with working hand in
hand with the feds while they'll go out
and audit companies make sure their
books and all their driver files are
kept like they should be
um it takes a lot of time and it's a lot
of one-on-one with the company that new
intern group also offers a course the
first Thursday of every month it's free
I think they hold it at the department
of safety sometimes a DMV if needed
where industry can come to us and we'll
kind of they can ask questions we kind
of go through a PowerPoint to try and
help them because a lot of these new
industries that might be smaller they
might not know what's their
responsibility as far as the federal
guidelines so we do that to first
Thursday of every every month for them
and that's a brief overview of what we
do at Troop G does anybody have any
questions
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
gentlemen thank you for your time
um let me see we're going to take five
minutes or so if that's okay
commissioner
um but the deal Department of
Transportation will be up next
okay welcome back everybody uh as I said
next up welcome uh commissioner Cass and
Company uh from the Department uh New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
good morning
good morning Mr chair thank you for uh
having us
um I was stopping talking to
representative Sykes during the break I
I didn't realize you had AV uh set up so
we would have brought the PowerPoint
instead of the hard copies but I'll know
for next time believe it or not I prefer
paper oh you do okay so maybe we're all
set there but uh so we'll step you
through it this is just a um a kind of a
high level overview of the Department's
organization structure and just some of
the current issues
um for everyone's awareness uh hope to
get through it fairly quick in order to
leave time for any questions that any of
you have have for us
so on
um
page one of the uh presentation we start
off with the Department's Mission which
is transportation Excellence enhancing
the quality of life in New Hampshire and
the Dot's purpose which is a fairly
lengthy purpose statement but I like to
summarize it in terms of uh delivering
quality Transportation projects and
services and a timely and customer
service manner
on the
um third or or this or the second slide
after the title slide is a as an
organizational chart of the department
um so and with me today I wanted to
introduce them so we are organized with
three Commissioners I'm Bill Cass I'm
the commissioner uh recently appointed
uh just before uh Christmas uh replacing
previous commissioner Victoria Sheehan
um I was previously the assistant
commissioning commissioner and chief
engineer and to my left Dave rodrigue
who was formerly the director of
operations at the department was uh
nominated and confirmed just before
Christmas as my replacement as the
assistant commissioner and chief
engineer
and on my right is Andre Brier who is
the Deputy Commissioner for the
department and has been in place for a
little over a year so
and congratulations to both of you by
the way thank you thank you
so um I mentioned the the structure so
this this page the the fine over over
um gives an overview of the five
divisions within the department and
typically the assistant commissioner
Dave
um pretty much oversees the operations
side of the house so that's project
development which are the seven bureaus
that are uh involved in developing the
uh the federal program
um as well as the Operations Division
which is responsible for all of the
um uh operations and maintenance of of
Highways Bridges traffic signals
everything else and we'll get into a
little bit of detail by each division
on the other side of the house which
generally rolls up and reports to the
Deputy Commissioner we have our division
of finance which oversees all of the um
Financial operations policy
Administration which is some of our
labor compliance and HR as well as the
non-highway in Bridge Transportation
facilities of Aeronautics railroads and
public transportation
so that at a snapshot is just generally
how where how we're structured
um on the next slide slide four just a
few facts and figures about the D.O.T
um we're staffed with about 1650
permanent positions and I say permanent
positions because we have a
large number of vacancies currently
which I'll speak to in a uh toward the
end of the presentation
we're responsible for overseeing and
maintaining about
um
2159 State Bridges uh and uh we are
responsible for inspecting uh close to
1700 Municipal Bridges so all of the
bridges in the State uh the dot is
responsible for inspecting and seeing
that they're safe and they uh we inspect
every bridge every two years
redless Bridges which are structurally
deficient Bridges we inspect every six
months to ensure that they're not
deteriorating more rapidly and they are
kept safe safety is our number one
objective
we also maintain uh about 4 600 sunline
miles of roadway
there are now the 300 miles of town
maintained roads so those are state
roads that are on our books as summer
maintenance but they are uh maintained
by cities and towns during the winter
for plowing a lot of those are uh the
tier four unnumbered state roads things
like that
our program tries to maintain a Paving
cycle of about every 500 about five
about once every 10 years a section of
roadways should get some some sort of
preventative maintenance treatment we
try to pave about 500 to 550 miles per
year to keep up with that
um in addition to the miles of pavement
we maintain about a hundred thousand
highway signs
68 million feet of striping our goal is
to stripe every road
um in in the state once a year
um
we have uh
we have not achieved that goal most most
recently but it still is our objective
um and we concentrate obviously on
getting the higher volume roads done
first
we maintain 440 traffic signals about
550 traffic beacons
we have 194 miles of active state-owned
Rail lines that we administer 25
publicly accessible airports and 11
local public transit systems that we
help oversee and the
conduit for all of the federal funding
that goes to support those
so those are some just high-level facts
and figures of just the general size and
scope of the dots purview
the budgetary scope
um slide six just gives a snapshot of
our
approximately of our budget in FY 2022
actual expenders were actual
expenditures were close to 600 million
dollars
we tend to break our budget up in
talking about it into two sides of the
budget so a lot of funding gets
channeled through the dot that goes to
you know a construction program and
Municipal Aid to cities and towns so of
that 600 approximately 600 million
dollar expenditures about 305 million
had gone out to construction projects or
to support for cities and towns our
operating budget
um
was about 282 million dollars so that
roughly the two main parts of our budget
and how we um
how we separate those
and um I won't get into the details here
other times we've done presentations
um primarily when we talk about 10-year
plan and things like that about the
varied uh sources of funding that go
into supporting the dot but we are
supported by Highway funds federal funds
Turnpike funds other funds and a
relatively small percentage of of
General funds we'll touch on that a
little bit and if we have more questions
we can answer that
so that's a high level overview of some
of the nuts and bolts what I'll do now
is I'll ask Andre to just kind of Step
through with some of the
um
UH responsibilities under his purview
and then I'll have Dave go through the
same with with uh with his bureaus as
well in his division so Andre
thank you commissioner
morning uh chairman members of the
committee my name is Andre Brier just by
a brief background I spent most of my
career as a as an Air Force pilot
retired Colonel type
was a transportation official on the
federal side then came into this job and
everybody congratulates commissioner
Cass and assistant commissioner rodrigue
I feel like I should be the one getting
congratulations because I get to work
with them it's really a pleasure we have
a really good team that that we've
formed on the Aeronautics side as the
commissioner said we have 25 open to the
public airports these are really uh as
many of you know who that have airports
in your districts these are these are
Transportation assets they're also
economic gateways into those communities
their search and rescue assets their
Homeland Security assets and and most of
all dearest my heart they're also
education assets because these are the
places we we've we hear about a
nationwide pilot shortage that's coming
as the Vietnam
um era of Pilots finally finally leaves
the industry this is where we grow our
new pilots and we our goal is to keep
every one of these airports vibrant and
uh and active
um we mostly operate as a pass-through
for the Federal grant money we dispensed
about 46 million uh last fiscal year we
are one of 10 block grant States what
that means is that 10 states around the
country have have been designated and
signed up to have increased authority to
act as a proxy for the FAA gives us a
little uh more flexibility in our grants
and also lets us engage with FAA at a
slightly higher level than states that
that aren't part of the block grant and
that's something we're happy to discuss
in more detail if any of you are more or
uh would like more information on it we
get about 400 plus thousand dollars in
Revenue uh every year from Aviation
registration fees generally that's
plowed right back into the system to
keep our non-federally funded airports
viable work on projects Etc the one one
thing the one capability you don't see
in this Aeronautics section we were also
privileged earlier in the spring to
brief the governor and executive Council
on our growing uas capability that's
that's the drones uas we at dot don't
take pictures people we take pictures of
things so this is runways roads it's a
great emergency response asset for us if
we're you know if a significant event
happens on our highway system or our
airports are as we're constructing
things this is a much cheaper more
effective way for us to uh to get that
capability versus Contracting it out so
we're very proud of that capability and
and that is growing but we do have a
wonderful briefing given by our uh our
great Aviation team if any of you is
interested in getting that we're happy
to come one-on-one or as a group to
present that to you
on the rail side we do have six Active
operator agreements as commissioner Cass
also said it's about 194 miles of
state-owned rail line
um we also have
333 inactive miles of rail line what we
do with that we're trying to be creative
at all times we have a couple of uh of
tourist railroads as you know
along with four freight services that we
contract out for we're always looking
for uh for things to do with those
inactive miles in order to preserve it
for potential future use but also make
sure the citizens of New Hampshire get
the most use out of it some of them that
you're probably aware of are rail Trails
some other are kind of the rail bikes
you see in certain services around the
state we're growing that capability as
well just so they can use that line
um we just completed a rail trail plan
in cooperation with our other colleagues
throughout state government that will be
forthcoming and and also provided to you
in the in the coming weeks
on the public transit side we have 11 uh
local public transit providers
um as you're aware the uh the event
since 2020 did have an impact on
ridership evolving commuting patterns
we're still tracking that
um generally speaking we see a steady
increase in ridership
not quite at pre-2020 levels but we're
getting there what you do see uh in just
about every municipality around the
state and around the country are
slightly different uh return to work
patterns uh in the Greater Boston area
you do see concentrated uh increases
almost to 2020 levels in the Tuesday
through Thursday time frame
um but that's evolving we have our eye
on it and we have great Partnerships
with our public transit uh providers
we're also really expanding into the
on-demand service for our elderly and
people with disabilities around the
state we've recently uh not recently I
guess it's it's it's over a year now
hired Mobility managers to further
streamline and integrate all those
wonderful options that our seniors and
people with disability can access to
give them easier One-Stop service when
they need a ride whether that's to
groceries medical appointments anything
like that to make sure we keep those
communities connected and that's our
goal
so that's my Aviation Rail and Transit
portfolio just briefly hitting on the
next slide
our Administration uh is responsible for
our executive office keeping the
Commissioners and directors moving in in
the same direction
um coordinating uh the funding that we
do for uh that we have to give to
outside agencies to continue doing what
we do we have a small But Mighty public
information section uh headed by Richard
Arkin who who a lot of you will see on
Mur from time to time and we also under
the direction of the commissioner uh
focus on management strategy
top to bottom review making sure we're
using our uh funds and assets and the
most effective and efficient way we can
on the finance side we have a an
excellent Finance section that deals
with budget formulation Financial
operations all the things you would
expect
I thought coming from the federal side
that I thought I knew colors of money
and how complex those could be I didn't
know anything
the the numbers of colors in the rainbow
of money that our finance section has to
deal with it's staggering and they do a
very effective job at it
finally our policy and administration
also deals with typical human resources
we have a very strong relationship with
dop we we operate hand in hand with them
on everything from
from Personnel system modifications
redesigned to operating as a test bed
for them we are a large agency so we uh
we are really proud and value that
partnership we have with Das and dop
um and we also make sure we keep all of
our contracts uh in compliance with
federal laws with our with our federal
compliance section and our internal
audit also helps in that regard as well
and Workforce analytics are something
the commissioner will touch on more as
we go through our presentation but that
is my portion of the presentation and
and thanks for your attention we're
happy to provide any of those briefings
to you uh if anything uh piqued your
interest
foreign
side of the house
so good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you so much for having
us to today to give you this overview of
of the department I'm going to start by
describing uh project Development
Division a project development division
is responsible for planning and
designing and constructing uh
Transportation projects
um the division includes the bureaus of
Highway design bridge design Bureau of
environment planning and Community
Assistance it works with a lot of the
municipalities and helps them in
delivering the municipally managed
projects and so forth
um and also includes
um
what else am I missing
Bureau of materials and research that
um helps make sure that we're specifying
the
um right materials for our projects and
then also helps to make sure we test the
products that the contractors provide to
make sure they they meet us
specifications
um we the project Development Division
delivers the the 10-year plan
um we have a current 10-year plan the 23
to
um 34 10-year plan and as soon as this
June we'll start developing the next
10-year plan that 10-year plan is
developed on a two-year cycle
um project development puts out projects
to expend about 225 million dollars of
federal funds each year mostly in
construction projects in fiscal year 22
57 new projects contracts were well that
in our Bureau of construction
administered over 84 active construction
projects
um in the advertised contract value is
233 million dollars for fiscal year 22.
shifting over to maintenance and
Operations Division these are the the
folks that that maintain
preserve and preserve that
transportation system on a daily basis
across the state we have six Highway
Maintenance districts
um that consist of about 87 Patrol
sections 87 Patrol sections sounds like
a lot but when you think of of the size
of New Hampshire that's about one Patrol
section for every two and a half to
three towns so they do cover a
significant area and those are the folks
that that plow the roads with a contract
rented equipment help trim the trees Mo
mow repair drainage and keep things
working and provide storm response and
so forth we also have our turnpikes
division that I'll get into a little bit
more detail on in a few minutes and
turnpike's Division
provides a lot of those same services
but is focused on the turnpike system
also included in operations is that
Bureau of traffic that does uh our
roadway line stripings takes care of our
signs and traffic signals Bureau of
traffic is responsible for speed limits
they also have a traffic research
section in a traffic engineering section
those are the things all the the
motorists notice the signs the the
pavement markings and so forth and we
can have a huge impact on safety by
making sure that those pavement markings
are refreshed on an annual cycle
um and signs are kept up today I Bridge
maintenance
um Bureau takes care of all of our
state-owned bridges including the lift
Bridges and in Portsmouth and does
preservation work and maintenance work
we work to strive to wash our bridges
every year to seal them every five years
and by making that investment in
maintenance reservation we really extend
the life of bridges which is very
important running a cost-effective
transportation system we have a bureau
of Mechanical Services
we have a fleet that's um worth just
over has a replacement value of just
over 110 million dollars that consists
of 1250 vehicles and and accessories the
bulk of that is a 340 heavy trucks most
of which but not all
um provide winter maintenance and also
includes those numbers also include 315
of the assault spreaders that that go in
those truck sets as well
we have a fuel distribution section that
maintains a a Statewide fueling
freed if you will or or fueling sites
um that fuel provides us our Diesel and
gasoline as well as all other state
agencies and municipals and non-profits
can also purchase their fuel from that
system
um it's very convenient for us most of
these fuel sites are located at our
facilities so obviously they're they're
available for US 24 7.
um and it also provides us a a little
bit of cushion
um should something happen in the in the
market whether due to
um some sort of emergency or other
purpose so we have fuel available for us
operations also includes a
transportation management center that's
located at the
um iPod the incident planning and
operations center in our transportation
management center helps to keep traffic
flowing every day by monitoring what's
going on and providing drivers real-time
information so that they can make
decisions I'm going to get into just a
little bit more detail about the highway
fund
um when a lot of people hear the highway
fund they think of Dot and it's
important for us to to explain that the
highway fund does not exclusively go to
Dot and
um the the highway fund is not also not
Dot's only funding source although it is
a a the most significant funding source
unrestricted Revenue
um in the highway fund is comprised the
the gas tax a road toll and registration
fees collected by Department of Safety
um also Federal construction
reimbursements gavi bonds and tiffia
proceeds flow through the highway fund
as as well
um the highway fund is a primary source
of funding for Opera for our operating
budget
um in revenue from the highway fund
um is also appropriated to other
agencies including safety the judicial
branch and the Department of Justice in
59.7 percent of the highway fund was
appropriated to dot
26.7 percent toddler agencies in 13.6
percent to municipalities
a little bit about the the turnpike
system it includes three three Turnpike
segments it's 89 miles long includes 172
Bridges seven toll facilities and the
most important thing about the the
turnpike system is it's an Enterprise
fund meaning the tolls that come in from
the turnpike must be spent to operate
maintain or expand the turnpike system
and they can't be spent on anything else
that that the department or others would
would like us to to spend those funds on
um so the turnpike is is self-funding
um the revenue pays for operating and
maintenance costs Debt Service renewal
and replacement work very important
that's that maintenance and preservation
work that helps to preserve the the
length and let us run a cost-effective
Turnpike system and Capital Improvements
in a fiscal year 22 we had 112 million
total transactions they yielded 123
million dollars in total revenue
so um I'll push this over I'll pause
there for a minute just to see if there
are any any questions I have a few
um issues and challenges that I was
going to kind of go through but we've
kind of covered a lot of details so I
just you know if there's any questions
about the operations of the department
maybe we can pause for a minute there
any well I see representative sakes
foreign
thank you commissioner
um there's a management strategy with
respect to Road repairs and so on where
you
spend the biggest bucket of money on
less damaged roads that will extend
their life much further and you're sort
of not ignore but you know put off the
really heavily damaged ones because it
costs so much more to do such a small
space do you take a look at that kind of
concept in the 10-year plan yes yes
absolutely and a lot of our
um
you know program Investments are uh you
know driven by our asset management
approach and our asset management
program Andre talked about some of that
um that that group with this with the
some of the asset management strategy
but um we have for a number of years
since around 2014 really been focused on
um particularly on the capital program
particularly through the 10-year plan
um uh you know preservation and
maintenance first and foremost taking
care of of what we have and
um you know part of that is through a
balanced approach keeping good roads in
good condition while still trying to uh
address the backlog of of uh roads and
pavement condition that are in poor
condition
um we have found in in and nationally
some of those Asset Management type
approaches have also you know kind of
proven true that you know a focus on uh
strictly worst first taking care of just
the worst first
um you never you never catch up and
um you know since we've really focused
on this Asset Management strategy
beginning in 2014
I go back to 2014 because we also had
some
um
additional Revenue through SB 367 that
that that allowed us to
um you know address particularly uh
you know some of the unbuilt roads and
some of the uh more rural uh roads
um we have we have we have we have data
that shows that you know our pavement
conditions Statewide system-wide is has
been consistently improving uh and the
number of Red List Bridges has
consistently been declining so our
pavement condition is is uh is up the
structurally deficient Red List bridges
are down which I think speaks to the
success of of
um you know our asset management
strategy strategy exactly what you're
asking about
yep my follow-up I was not a follow-up a
different question if you make okay I
have another one
thank you
um Mr chairman
um
several years ago this committee I think
it was several years ago this committee
and this house
passed a bill that changed the fee
structure for aircraft registrations and
one of the concerns that some of us had
at that time was that it would adversely
they were trying to lower the prices to
make
some airports more competitive with
other airports in other states and I
wondered how that
sugared out over the last little bit in
terms of revenues
yeah thank you sir
it's one of my big questions too when I
came on board and uh you know the bottom
line is we've reached an equilibrium and
I think we have a good Pace now where
we're utilizing those funds in the most
effective way we can helping as I as I
mentioned earlier uh non-uh non-federal
funded airports obviously could we do
more with more the answer is yes
uh but what we seek to do is use those
resources that you in this chamber
give to us in the most effective way we
can but uh I will never turn down some
additional funds if they're coming our
way
let me does anybody else have a question
let me in all fairness representative
representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman um
gentlemen one of your uh
unrestricted Revenue funds is the gas
tax
and obviously as Society is turning over
to EV there's going to be a declination
there
um do you have a plan to adjust for that
I I can I can speak to that uh and a
little bit I had a couple more slides to
cover and if uh one of the issue one of
the longer term issues that I was going
to address so
take it in context there or I can take
it now however you want me to okay yeah
please because I'm looking at the clock
now we are we do have a few more
speakers so uh represent was there
anybody else from the committee
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering if uh
you could speak briefly about the
renumbering uh exit number system and
and where we are with that
certainly
um
there is a a you know nationally
um the standard is to have exit numbers
on on the interstates and freeways
um correlate to mileage reference uh
numbers
um New Hampshire has never embraced that
and we have kind of put off
um
complying with that for for for some
time we're tourist oriented State we
don't have
um you know real real long sections of
Interstate that uh you know where it may
be more beneficial and things things
like that
um
so over the last couple of years because
of that Federal mandate we have brought
it up through the 10-year plan we have
proposed a couple of of projects mainly
because
um
to show good faith to the federal
requirements that that we were bringing
it up as an issue
um the last two times that it has come
up through the 10-year plan with the
executive Council and through the
governor 's office
it has
it has not been embraced or not been
endorsed so where where we're at a um
I think Andre's word was unique
equilibrium there
um there's a there's a case to be made
on on both both sides of the issue
um I am not a a
it's not an issue that I think we're
going to fall on our sword over unless
Federal Highway
has some more stringent requirements
um right now we we keep monitoring it
and say we'll work on it and bring it up
but there hasn't been the support for it
publicly and um
so that that's kind of where it stands I
will say that you know recently
Massachusetts within the last couple of
years has has changed Vermont has dual
postings on their signs Massachusetts
changed a while ago I think
um you know New Hampshire and maybe
Delaware are one of the only two states
in the country that do not
um
uh by standard do exit number exit
numbering on the interstate it's it's
sequential and not mile referenced
marking but
um over time as as that goes on if there
is support for that uh we we if there is
support for it we we can see and address
it to come in to
um
you know consistent consistency with the
rest of the country but
um
there are times when New Hampshire likes
to stand out and and be independent so
we we respect that
appreciate that thank you it'll always
be Exit 32 to me so
is that something that can hold off when
we are running a light on time
representative sellers had one
okay I appreciate it we can get all the
information we need these gentlemen are
always available and and hear quite a
bit so
um if you wanted to finish up your
project very quickly and I'll go through
some of the issues so I'm on slide uh
uh 14
um just some of the issues and
challenges just I wanted everybody to be
aware of and hopefully I don't I don't
think they know that they shouldn't be
any surprise but some of the issues
particularly this budget season and
forward that we're dealing with tend to
be
um you know issues associated with
inflation we're seeing increased labor
and material costs and it has a
significant impact on our budget most of
the additional needs that we have
identified in the budget process for
example tend to resolve around
inflationary impacts particularly for
materials type of purchases we use a lot
of um we use a lot of fuel we use a lot
of salt
those are some of the larger Commodities
and those have all
gone up by you know 50 to 100 percent so
they have real impacts on the budget we
are also con we are also impacted by
supply chain issues and path budgets and
past things we have had support for
equipment
um and other commodity purchases uh
particularly on the fleet we have had a
a law a struggle in the last two years
um fulfilling some of those purchase
orders so we have a number of
um
uh a certain amount of funds um
obligated that are that are in process
but we're finding that the industry they
just can't deliver and they just can't
fulfill some of those purchase orders in
addition we're seeing increased costs of
of uh you know trying to buy equipment
and stuff like that so those are issues
the biggest issue that we have been
confronted with in the last year coming
out of the pandemic and I don't think
we're unique compared to the rest of the
state has been you know Workforce
shortages in the amount of vacancies
that we have so we have been dealing
with historically High vacancy rates at
the department in the order of
um 22 24 so that's one of approximately
every four positions in the department
is is is vacant
um and
um with the historically low
unemployment rate and with the uh you
know some of the compensation rates that
the that the state structure offers
we're having difficulties attracting and
retaining employees and in particular I
heard some of the discussion with DMV
was
um attracting and hiring snow plow
operators which requires CDL licenses
we did have uh and you may be aware of
it at the end of at the beginning of the
fall through the fiscal committee and
through government Council we did get
approved along with uh Department of
Safety and others a
a
Recruitment and Retention bonus of about
five thousand dollars per employee so
that has helped
um at least stem stem the tide I don't
think it's brought a lot of new
employees in but it has helped
um I think stand stem the tide so we
have found since since that past that
you know our uh vacancy rate has kind of
stagnated it around that 22 20 24
percent and that some some some Bureau
some areas are higher some areas are
lower but that's a department-wide
average so
it is an issue that we are continuing to
deal with
um hopefully
um
tentative collective bargaining
agreement uh will will also be a a
positive impact on on some of that as as
well too
and I bring that up because it is
affecting productivity as we have had
these vacancies we are
moving people around moving resources
around to focus on
um
you know the critical areas that we need
to get done but as a result there are
other areas not getting done for example
um I mentioned our goal of trying to
stripe all of the um all of the highways
every year
we typically bring on somewhere in the
order of uh 35 to 40 seasonal employees
to help with
um with uh with the striping through the
through the year and we have not been
able to hire those and we are relying on
permanent employees particularly in the
patrol sections in the in the in the
maintenance districts to fill those
positions and get the striping done
the downfall is that's taking people
away from their regular jobs that uh you
know leads to you know some deferred
maintenance and reduce preventative
maintenance which could have longer term
implications
similarly this winter to help uh fill in
some of the vacancies and gaps with uh
winter maintenance we have about
80 to 85 people that have volunteered to
do winter maintenance activities
um that's great we we need them that's
our priority in the winter but those are
people being taken away from their
regular day jobs so there are bridge
maintenance activities and things like
that that would take place during the
winter that aren't getting done so it is
one of the issues and challenges that
that we are continuing to deal with and
monitor
um on slide 15 uh so those are more of
the immediate challenges and stuff that
I just wanted to to discuss but
um representative Jones you had talked
about the the funding issues and and you
know longer term challenges does become
uh some funding issues there is
insufficient Highway fund Revenue to
fund current levels of of service we
don't match
um
we we don't provide State matching funds
for the federal program we rely on
something called called Turnpike toll
credits because of our Turnpike system
we are allowed to use federal funds at a
hundred percent
um
but we don't provide we don't bring any
state money to match those federal funds
unlike a lot of other states we have
limited State funds for addressing
non-federal eligible state state roads
about a third of our state mileage is
not eligible for federal funds so we
um
scrape and and try to get those
addressed with the limited amount of
State funds that we have but that is a
an issue of concern and you mentioned
representative Jones the declining road
toll revenues electric vehicles do have
a impact on that but we have also looked
at the increasing fuel efficiency of the
national Fleet and that continues to
have an incremental erosion of the of
the road toll
issues
um so a short answer to your question uh
other than pointing out the issues uh we
don't we don't we don't have a a a a
good plan
um other than to point out that uh what
the levels of service would be and and
where our shortfalls are but it's not a
new issue
um going back a number of years the
state highway fund has depended on a
whole series of of one-time fixes to
help
um
to help balance the the highway fund
um there's been registration fees
surcharges there has been some
asset trans transfers between the
turnpike system and the highway fund
um
and uh most recently at the end of the
last biennium the legislature put 50
million dollars of general fund Surplus
into the highway fund that helps balance
the budget helps balance the highway
fund through this biennium but it is a
it is a longer term issue
um
um that that that we continue to Monitor
and and and discuss with the policy
makers
so that's the I hate to close on a
bummer of a note but you know that it is
a kind of effect
the final couple of charts there I would
would point out
um you know
um slide uh 17 does show the number of
personnel over over time and uh the
issues in uh you know and the vehicle
miles traveled that has continued to
grow up and the point of this slide is
to is to point out I think we are an
efficient organization we continue to do
more with less uh we continue to build
highways vehicle mile travel the use of
the highways is up and uh you know are
you know going back to 2012 2013 when
when we had uh significant Workforce
reduction we have continued to keep up
and do more with less so I think
um it does speak to and shows
graphically that uh we are an efficient
organization we strive to continue to be
an efficient organization
uh the last couple of slides on slide 18
are the types of issues that we tend to
come before the transportation committee
things like speed limits I know there's
a bill this afternoon talking about
um pedestrian traffic signals things
things like that so those are the types
of issues that dot would be before the
transportation committee with
and lastly I just wanted and I won't get
through all these uh bullets there's a
lot of information that I did want to
emphasize just make a
the committee aware of there is a New
Hampshire Transportation Council that
was established by the legislature in
it has representation from house
Transportation Senate Transportation as
well as industry
experts in the goal of that committee is
to help
make recommendations in dealing with
multimodal Transportation issues
transportation services and other
alternative transportation needs so new
and emerging Technologies the
transportation Council can be a
a resource to help
to help the transportation committee or
help other committees you know research
and get information
it is a standing it is a standing
Council but um I I know in the path
there have been a number of legislative
study commissions around different
issues of transportation and the
transportation Council can help be a
resource to research and help study some
of those issues that if you as a
committee feel you don't have enough
context or information on to make a
um to make a decision on that can be a
resource so with that uh uh Mr chair
thank you for your time and attention I
hope we were respective of of your time
and the information was useful
absolutely thank you very much
um but speaking of time I'm going to
hold off with questions these they're
always available as a matter of fact
some may be back this afternoon because
we do have a couple of bills uh and
there are a few other people that I
invited to introduce themselves briefly
that we do deal with not all that much
but nonetheless uh we do so thank you
again very much thank you very much sir
and speaking of that I see Captain
Eastman Fish and Game
what
well you have enough time enough time oh
yeah
in an effort to conserve your time I I
will uh just go over this pamphlet
briefly and about who we are and how you
may see me in in some of your
proceedings who are you again
I'll get right to that
I'm captain Michael Eastman I work for
New Hampshire fishing game law
enforcement Division I am the ohrv or
the off Highway Recreation vehicle
coordinator I oversee uh the ohrv
enforcement which would include
snowmobiles and we also go into safety
and the registration program
so the department broken up into many
divisions uh from the executive
director's office
right down to uh Fisheries marine
fisheries wildlife
um and then like I said marine fisheries
law enforcement being a part of the
um of the law enforcement being one of
the divisions within fish and game
um
I think how best to kind of relate uh
how you will see Fish and Game in front
of your committee would be more than
likely in the uh off Highway Recreation
vehicle Realm
um obviously off Highway recreation
vehicles including snowmobiles are very
important to our state and how we
operate them
in relation to tourism for the state is
very important I work very closely with
these different user groups
um and uh
you know it once again at
some of these ohrvs are operated on uh
State roadways and then that also
creates some issues obviously within
um on these state roads towns within
themselves can operate or choose to
allow them to be operated on roadways
so I I think you know more than not how
you will see me as I said is is with
these issues as they come up
um you know once again these are off
Highway recreation vehicles some people
feel that they should be operated as
conventional Motor Vehicles even though
they that's not how they are designed
and really I think at the end of the day
what I've looked to do and I'm sure you
do as well is that when we have folks
that come to our state to to recreate
that they have a good time doing that
and that they don't
um end up at the hospital or even worse
at the uh at the funeral home so I think
at the end of the day that's that's what
we're all looking to do I can certainly
take questions
um I I can certainly pontificate on on
what law enforcement division does
um and I'm sure you've seen what we do
on the news so
thank you very much thank you uh does
anybody have any questions
I've seen that I don't I don't think I
don't think we have any bills this year
that we might see you with
I'm not that I've seen so far yeah there
are a few out there nonetheless I I know
you do come here from time to time and I
just wanted everybody on the committee
to put a face with the department so
that when their shoes come up they know
who to reach out to so
thank you very much for allowing us to
or for allowing me to be here today
thank you
and the last Department that I invited
today I I do know we're going to be
seeing a little bit of Marine Patrol
foreign
thank you chairman um members of the
committee thank you so much I'm just
going to start while uh Lieutenant
McLean just um we are going to put a
PowerPoint up we're just going to talk
through it though
um we won't we won't talk off of it uh
we also have some handouts on because
mainly at the end of it it has our
contact information so if you wish to
have any questions or do anything
afterwards we will try to do a condensed
version of this but absolutely we're
open to any questions
um that you that you may have
um
I'll just give you a quick introduction
to myself
um Lieutenant Dennis Wade I'm the unit
Commander uh at State Police Marine
Patrol
I've only been over there since May so
um I am learning a lot it is it is a a
very busy unit we do we certainly do a
lot and a lot more than I I ever knew I
can tell you that we also have an
extremely
um uh extremely great staff uh very hard
working very dedicated not just to their
job but I I would say to the mission of
Marine Patrol
um
the
and once Lieutenant McLean's on I'll
have her introduce himself to I also
have um and some of you may well know um
uh retire Captain uh Tim Dunleavy
who was in the position prior to me
um he is retired but he has been nice
enough just like many other state
employees to go back and work part-time
and keep all his knowledge uh give me
all his knowledge that he has so he is
in the back certainly if we have any
questions and I I brought both of them
to make sure we can answer any questions
that you do have
um
uh State Police Marine Patrol is um
obviously the we are the main agency
within the state to for the
responsibilities of protecting our
Waters making sure they're safe making
sure they're enjoyable
and uh making sure that the people who
not only live here or live on the lakes
and use them every day but those who
come to New Hampshire especially during
the summer months can enjoy them
um
our our legislative responsibilities
include
um certainly law enforcement
boating education
our navigational Aid System uh and our
Mooring system and I'll also add in our
commercial licensing and Commercial
vessel inspection unit or Insurance a
unit but our section
uh so
these these things keep us quite busy
throughout the year
um and our law enforcement unit even
though you would you would think it was
just the law enforcement officers out
there the Marine Patrol officers
um it is all included with our
maintenance and support staff I will say
this about Marine Patrol is is each unit
does not work
um uh in the independently we all work
together uh without one of those three
sections right there uh we we wouldn't
be able to get our job done every day
our maintenance crew uh does a
phenomenal job of keeping our 66 vessels
that we currently have in inventory uh
up and ready to go every day all day
long including today
um I will say this and you'll see this
later in one of the uh one of the one of
the photos is we do have three
maintenance positions right now we only
have one filled two of them shortly
after I came on decided to retire I'm
hoping that wasn't because of me uh our
our supervisor mechanic was around for
35 years
um luckily similar to miss to Captain
Dunleavy he is in the process of trying
to come back to us to do some uh some
work for us so our one mechanic who has
been left for the last several months is
doing a phenomenal job he's one of those
guys you walk in the office every day
he's always got a smile on his face even
though if he's doing the work of three
people our support staff obviously we
have a um we have our own budget within
Marine Patrol we have we do our own
hiring we do our own training and with
all the new law enforcement duties out
there and training that's required by
the state and the federal government we
need to keep track of all that so there
is a lot to do and our entire team works
works together uh every day
our law enforcement our Marine Patrol
officers uh work around the state year
round
um and I say year-round uh while I was
in the back there I was just checking
um we have one uh two of our officers
out on one of our boats out on the ocean
right now we do we do Patrol 12 months
out of the year in fact in the last
several weeks we've been on
Winnipesaukee probably for the first
time in January in many years so much
that it hit Facebook and people were
quite surprised that we were out there
but our job is not to just be out there
stopping boats and checking for
registrations but our just our job is to
be out there for safety looking around
the shorelines making sure things aren't
floating in the waters uh in the past of
of other boats that are going by quite a
few of the commercial vehicles and
companies that work on the islands on
Winnipesaukee are actually getting quite
a bit of work done which they were a
little bit surprised to see us because
the registrations
but we're not about out there but just
enforcement we're about there about
education so we've had some contact with
them uh funny one of them one of them
was stop no registration I was told
called by DMV that the next day he came
to register his vote because he had been
stopped after January 1st out on the
lake which is again very rare but we
want to make sure everyone knows that
we're out there doing our job 12 months
out of the year
uh
there are approximately 975 lakes in
this this state and uh where our
jurisdiction is any uh any body of water
over 10 acres that's within the state in
the borders of New Hampshire whether
it's man-made private or public so that
that's quite a few Lakes we do Patrol
about 265 of those the rest of those are
either an accessible uh can't get boats
into them they don't have not
necessarily lakes that allow motors on
them so we do less enforcement on those
and plus with the larger Lakes we have I
did notice that some of you were from
the districts that have some of our
larger Lakes so you're probably quite
familiar maybe more familiar with what
we do but everybody I'm sure has water
in their district and we're basically
responsible for that water
um our our Law Enforcement Officers
themselves basically break up into three
categories both to fixed and field
patrols our field patrols although
mostly those seasonal officers who get
uh get a get a boat for the summer they
drive around from Lake to Lake River to
River and Patrol most of them are uh the
seasonals they drive around their own
personal vehicles they get them to the
lakes and rivers they do the patrols and
they go home at the end of the day our
other two are the fix fixed patrols
similar to Winnipesaukee similar to
Squam winter Squam where our boats are
on those Lakes docked all year long
available at any time for officers to go
and get onto them those officers are
dedicated to those lakes and they're
very very familiar with those Lakes the
other one as I was just mentioning was
our ocean
uh we do have a vote that we we docked
down at the coast guard as well as
Hampton docks in our summertime so we
have two boats during the summer time
one during the winter time
um and that keeps our that keeps our
field area our field patrols going
throughout the year
um we Patrol the waterways we enforce
boating laws we respond to uh calls for
service uh emergencies or
non-emergencies we might work very
closely uh with fish and game
um who is just here uh we support them
they support us and we actually work
very closely they also have one of their
boats on our docks at the lake Lake
Winnipesaukee so we see them quite often
we also provide Homeland Security
especially down on the coast we after 9
11 the federal government decided that a
lot of our infrastructure needed that
support needed that Patrol we have LPG
tankers coming in we have U.S Navy ships
submarines coming in
uh throughout the year to the Naval
Shipyard and we are asked by the U.S
Coast Guard whose primary jurisdictions
with those vessels to assist them with
Patrol and and support as those days
they come into our Harbors uh we also do
maintenance of our navigation system and
we also do commercial operating
uh testing as well as commercial
vegetable inspections we do about 500
vessels and about five to six hundred
commercial tests each year
um you would think of a commercial
vehicle such as a large boat maybe a
tourism boat but these go all the way
down to the smaller boats that have just
engines on them from camps that the camp
counselors would get the kids out on the
water maybe to it maybe to a an island
or to go out and do something for the
day that is considered a commercial
vessel so that needs to be inspected and
those operators need to have a license a
commercial license to do starting that
was kind of my first introduction to
Marine Patrol when I got there back in
May that's when all those those camps
start coming in those Camp counselors
the camp owners uh come into Marine
Patrol May and June and you might not
have time to really talk to us too much
because the staff there is is basically
running all day long trying to take care
of all the people coming in to try to
get their their licensing and vessels
inspected
um
love no um obviously I talked about the
Seacoast there's only 21 20 miles of
shoreline between Massachusetts and
Maine that New Hampshire but we have
about 158 miles of Shoreline so if you
go up oh up the Lakes up I mean up the
river uh there's quite a bit to do on
one of the few patrols I've been able to
do out there with Sergeant O'Connor who
is our ocean supervisor
um we probably touched maybe 25 of of
the areas that that we have to patrol
down there it takes quite a bit
um and you don't just drive at a high
speed up and down up and down the river
you have to take it slow you have to
really do your Patrol so this takes
quite a bit of time to do um we work
very closely and I mean very closely
with the United States Coast Guard
um a good portion of our funding also
comes from the Coast Guard Coast Guard
is responsible for recreational boating
uh the recreational boating industry in
the United States so they are the ones
who
um give a large portion of uh of of the
funds to all the states
um we work very closely with them we're
there every day we actually have an
office uh out there at the Coast Guard
Station
um and uh we're there every day so they
asked for our assistance we asked for
their assistance and it's it's a good
good Force multiplier
so the um uh one of the several of the
the larger sections I would like to talk
about is
um both both our um our navigation and
our Mooring section our navigation
section
um is uh
is we make our own buoys at our at our
office we we purchase all the um
uh we purchase all the supplies our
mechanics our people there put all that
stuff together we have over 2 000 buoys
and navigational markers throughout the
state obviously um one something happens
to one up in in the North Country we
have to send someone all the way up
there to do it
um and and I know I'm kind of getting
off of this but I know you're shorthand
and I mean I know you're short for time
but I I want to hit some major points
um and the reason I want to bring up the
navigation and going up the north
um we don't have a lot of manpower to go
up and do that with of actually bringing
back one of our um one of our our
supervisor mechanic who just left us and
he's going to come back and try to help
us with that last year when I got there
I realized a lot of the officers were
out dealing with Moorings
um and and navigational buoys trying to
fix them get them put back into the
water that's taking time off of the
officers time to be actually on the
waters patrolling so we're actually
going to try to try to bring them some
part-time seasonal help to specifically
go and do that
um one of my sergeants last year had to
take an entire day
live up to Lake and begog to fix two
buoys and to come all the way back so
there's a lot of these these little um
these things that a lot of people don't
see that we're trying we're trying to
work on and try to use our Manpower the
best we can
um we have again we have over 2 000 both
buoys lights and regulatory signs
throughout the uh throughout the state
on mostly the larger Lakes but you'll
also see them on the smaller Lakes
um
good yeah
our Mooring section so our Moorings
actually takes up quite a bit of our
time there's eight Lakes within the
state that have to have if you want to
have a mooring for your boat you do need
to have a permit
uh you have to put an application we
review it and I'm very strict about
reviewing it and trying to look at the
rules and the laws
the little Preamble in front of the law
for for Moorings actually states that
the legislature actually put put this
law into place so the Moorings are not
dotting our shorelines
um and causing a navigational Hazard or
as well as just a visual
um issues but at the same time if you
own if you won't own a boat and you
don't really have a dock system where
you have a poor Shoreline to do it you
need the place to put that boat so uh
this takes up a lot of our time during
the summer there's about 5
000 Moorings out there within the state
about we get about 2 500 applications
each year
um and then you uh you renew every year
through our through our system
um so uh last big portion of is our
border education so last year we handed
out about 8 000 boater certificates
they're not licenses they're voter
certificates you can either take this
class in person and take a test at the
end of the day or you can actually study
online and take it on uh and come into a
proctored exam you can also do a test
out which we only had about six of those
last year meaning you think you have
enough knowledge to do this you've been
doing it for maybe a lifetime and you
can come in and you can test out we also
have a 14-day agent program which if
you're a visitor to the state you've
never really been on the water but you
decided you want to rent a boat you can
come in one of our Mooring our permit
agents mostly the marinas look at the
look at the computer study a little bit
and you take a test at the end and
you'll you'll receive a 14-day
certificate which is only good for those
14 days while you're here in New
Hampshire so you can safely operate or
boat our biggest thing is just safety
and education that's what we're there
for although we do enforcement um
obviously we want to make sure
everybody's safe there's a lot of a lot
of young kids a lot of new boaters out
there and if you've my first experience
on Lake Winnipesaukee if you've never
been out there on a boat you may look at
it from the hills and the mountains are
driving by I suggest you go out there
someday and it's it's a whole new
experience if you're actually hot on the
water
the last thing is I'm just going to show
you just talk about real quickly just
some of the things we're working on some
of the projects and some of our issues
that are going on there is a there is a
a bill currently in to have a a
committee put together
to study the vessel numbering rules as
well as registration fees so currently
we take in money through registration
fees that are disbursed to other
agencies by the U.S Coast Guard
regulations
that that can't be done they are working
with us to try to get that done there
are several other states that are also
having that issue so we've actually
talked directly with U.S Coast Guard and
these other states to try to come up
with a solution to try to find and
mostly this is uh
environmental safe Environmental
Services search and rescue for fish and
game and uh Port Authority down down in
the Portsmouth area so we're trying to
work on that and they're going to be
trying to come up with a study committee
to do that we do have a large doc
project at our building our dock down on
our building is 30 years old it's not
cheap to replace we put it out once
we've had to rebid it
um and we're hoping to get that done for
for next winter whereas our entire doc
system is going to be taken out and and
changed up we
Recruitment and Retention like everybody
else talks about I think we're good at
retention I think we're we're having a
hard time with recruitment currently we
only have about 26 seasonal officers
that's historically low in this in this
unit we have numbers of um uh we used to
be in the 80 90 to 100 number range of
seasonal officers now last year we had
26 we're probably going to be in that
range again this year with with 10
full-time officers so not a lot to go
around to patrol in the state and the
last thing is we we do a uh we are doing
a a program with the troopers on the
road many of whom actually started with
Marine Patrol so they have the knowledge
they're coming back in they're helping
us do patrols that's augmenting our our
patrols a little bit
um it's been it's been a huge success
last year was great we're trying to
improve upon that this year so we are
busy we are 12 months out of the Year
everyone thinks kind of things slow down
after after uh after the fall which they
do maybe on the water but it certainly
doesn't do that for the Marine Patrol
Bureau
um you do have handouts on the bottom of
that is our phone number as well as our
email address we're available anytime
any questions uh more than happy to
answer those for you
thank you very much thank you
and for again for questions
because of time uh let's we can reach
out to them directly and we'll be seeing
them very shortly as well
um speaking of that as you can see now
and I think representative Sykes can
attest one of the toughest jobs I have
is time management sometimes you can hit
it sometimes it don't
um there are two other people in the
room that I said if I had time at the
end I would let them introduce
themselves
I don't have time but I'm still going to
let you introduce yourselves briefly
please first is Dan Bennett
um the lucky position of being the
lobbyists who sit between you and lunch
so I will be brief
um my name is Dan Bennett I'm with the
New Hampshire Automobile Dealers
Association we're a trade group for the
motor vehicle industry in New Hampshire
we represent about 560 businesses uh
about 15 000 employees we are a car
truck motorcycle snowmobile ATV
construction farm equipment
franchised and independent members so we
are the big garage mahals that you see
and we are the little string of lights
guys so we cover the entire motor
vehicle industry
um
we also you'll see periodically you'll
hear from me very frequently during the
session you'll also hear from our team
at dennehan boulay who assists with some
things a Cornerstone issue for nhada is
roadway safety
um we'll be here very frequently talking
about safe roads through annual
inspections through driver's education
motorcycle rider education and also just
generally the distracted driving law uh
we're here very frequently on so we have
two programs I'd want to mention to you
I do have a handout that's going to
summarize all this stuff and importantly
it has my contact information my cell
phone number email any any information
that I can provide for you we have a
complaint program that helps resolve
autocap it's called autocap it resolves
complaints between consumers and dealers
that are in our association the AGS
office actually sends about two 200 or
so cases a year over to us and we
resolve them because they're actually
just not staffed to handle it
um so we handle it for them so if you
have a constituent concern this is a
great program uh to get them some Aid
typically it's just a miscommunication
issue a Salesman misstated something
um and the owner didn't know about it or
the customer just didn't really get what
tires for life really means so uh
communication connection can solve a lot
of differences we've found with great
success so it'll be a real value to your
constituents we also offer an education
program we scholarship about a hundred
thousand dollars a year to Young
technicians that want to move into the
automotive industry to work on vehicles
technology is emerging at a at a
tremendous Pace cost of Education even
through the Community College we've got
20 high school programs five community
colleges we help get folks through the
system pay for classes pay for tools so
that they can kind of become the
lifeblood of our Workforce we believe in
a home-grown Workforce and that's why we
support the program through our
Education Foundation
um
we have a number of agency partners that
we work with most frequently Department
of Safety and DMV who you heard from
earlier
um sad to see that they're not here to
hear my comments but I think it's good
that they're not here because it means I
mean them I've worked with the DMV for
over 20 years never in their history
have they been firing on as many
cylinders as they are right now through
director marasco has built a team that
is focused on customer service and that
includes industry they're doing some
tremendous work and some tremendous
Innovation out there so I give them real
Kudos please know from our seat there's
the DMV isn't is in a great place right
now under his leadership Lieutenant
O'Leary who you heard from Troop G
um is a a great individual to work with
he's um he's accessible and Troop G is
solution oriented and that's what
industry needs so we really thank them
for that I'm glad they were here to
present to you so other than that at the
end of the day later on you'll be
hearing from us on a few bills I will
hand out the information that has my
contact information anything
with connections that I can make with a
business in your local community they
are the true experts I can be of
assistance and provide some information
so thank you for your time thank you Mr
chairman
thank you and thank you it gives me some
thought and I do want to give you a
better opportunity so I can still
schedule something in extended
orientation in the future if you'd like
another another opportunity but I think
once you start talking with everybody
we'll probably be fine thank you again
and we'll see you soon field trip
ah we're talking thank you just just to
be fair Mr Tom praisal
huh
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'll be very brief um as Dan
said this is the most dangerous place to
for a lobbyist to be
um so my name is Tom prasall I'm with
Demers and pray saw we're a lobbying
firm here in Concord uh we have about 40
clients
um our team is comprised of myself James
Demers Sean Thomas and Jonathan Melanson
we have of our clients there's several
that will come before this committee so
I'll just list them for you and you'll
be seeing one of us quite frequently but
we represent the New Hampshire driver
education Teachers Association
Enterprise Rent-A-Car FedEx
calcamai Enterprises which provides the
educational materials for voter safety
hunter education ATV snowmobiles we also
represent the New Hampshire Police
Association the New Hampshire Troopers
Association and I'm sure there's others
that I've forgotten but we will be here
before you so just wanted to introduce
myself if you ever have any questions we
might be able to help you with we will
try to find the answer
um within reason
thank you very much thank you and they
they are both very good resources uh
it's not what you normally think of a
lobbyist
um they actually can find the answers
for you if you need them one more second
and then I'll let I know we got to get
to lunch uh just for everybody's
knowledge we do I did finally just get
the official list we have 23 bills not
too bad last year we had 52 I believe
including our retained bills so
um the other thing we've got a few new
members
um of our new members because we I just
wanted to touch briefly on how the
public hearings work are you on Town
boards or been in the meeting setting
before
and you know it's okay so they all kind
of work the same uh the whole the whole
idea is that we're here to listen to the
public uh seek information ask questions
uh we don't get involved with debates uh
we don't go back and forth with uh with
the with the people testifying uh it's
not a time for us to be giving our
speeches uh although people like to do
lead off comments occasionally
um
all questions go through the chair as
you can see
um and it's just again keeping the
structure that we need from the public
hearings any questions I'll answer them
on the site if you need or I'm a firm
believer that the best way to learn is
to watch and do and so we'll be doing
that this afternoon uh I picked five
bills
I gave more time than they probably need
I can get pretty aggressive when I do
schedule public hearings but I figured
today I'd give them more time and I
think they need uh just to give us more
opportunity to maybe ask and answer
questions uh or at least get to know
each other so have a good lunch sorry
we're a few minutes late
the one o'clock is the next hearing I'm
glad you mentioned that Vice chair
Gorski is going to be doing those some
double booked I'd be at another meeting
at one but I'll be back as soon as I can
like
assistant
no oh
okay let's rock and roll good afternoon
everybody and
Welcome to our public hearing on HB
54 Dash FN
which is relative to anti-car
inspections
and the chair recognizes
the sponsor
Mike Moffett
thank you Mr very exciting to be in this
Commit This historic committee my first
time to uh visit in this capacity
so very uh short simple hopefully sweet
measure in front of you and there's
really two parts two changes to existing
statute
um one of them simply changes uh the the
the month that we would be looking for
these uh inspections to take place uh
from April to May
uh in the let me say this I'm originally
from coax County
um Groveton way up North and where I
come from where I came from typically
we'd be snowmobiling in early April and
um it's a little different down here and
I guess you know the climate maybe is
what it used to be so as you look around
today you don't see the same snow in in
salt and sand but again coming from up
there
I'm used to
early April being still winter sometimes
you never know that means happened down
here as well so the thinking being from
pushing this back from April to May with
older antique vehicles that maybe aren't
rust proof you know the way that other
vehicles are uh it just might be a
little easier on some cars and some
venues for certain reasons to push it
from April to May so there's there's
that
and then the second part the other part
of the change that we're looking at here
um has to do with the the need to
re-inspect a vehicle that just hasn't
been used much uh most antique older
type vehicles
are you see them in Memorial Day parades
or whatever but they typically
often just don't get you they're not
driven that much
so we put in
um the metric of 5 000 miles in the
preceding two years and so we think that
makes a little bit more sense so this
bill will now be the property of this
committee and if uh of course those
numbers you can change it as you will
but that's it that's the two pieces of
uh the statute that we like to update
and hopefully improve
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative O'Hara
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um how did you come up with the
5 000 miles just inquiring sure uh
actually I was speaking to a constituent
who uh is actually here and will
probably uh have some words to say uh
who has several uh antique or or uh
older vehicles
and so that that metric that 5 000 mile
uh figure reflects conversations I've
had uh with him and others and like I
said that uh obviously is something that
you could change uh one way you know
could make it greater or less depending
upon you know the sentiment of the
committee
Representatives Sinclair thank you
um you forgive my ignorance on this but
an antique vehicle only becomes an
antique vehicle with a designated
antique plate or is it after it's 25
years old
thank you representative that's a great
question and to make sure you get the
best answer I'm going to uh defer to the
next uh person to testify who actually
has antique vehicles and in several
different states and I'm sure he'd be
happy to speak to the to the how antique
Vehicles Define it's a great question
that that I'd like to understand a
little bit better myself because uh you
know I may have an antique vehicle
myself someday and I want to know what
it takes to be an antique so that's not
a great answer but that information is
coming at you in just a couple minutes
thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chair
um representative Moffett
how do you envision the
confirmation of the five thousand miles
who would be responsible to do that
sure when a vehicle is inspected uh
typically is you know registered or
inspected there's a note made of the
mileage from the odometer
so
that information would be documented in
the paperwork that would go uh you know
the inspecting agency whatever would
make that that notation and again
um I the following speaker who's been
through this process many times could
also speak to that probably a little bit
better better than than I am
representative C
thank you Mr chairman
um I was just curious if uh the
inspection requirements were different
for antique Vehicles as compared to
regular Vehicles newer ones
thank you guys have another excellent
question and uh
for the third time I am gonna in all
Candor in all honesty I'm gonna defer to
someone who's who's been in that world
for a long time and uh that's an
excellent question and uh
I will find that answer if you don't get
it in the next five or ten minutes I
will find that answer for you
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um how many times can you use the 5 000
mile exemption is is it limited to one
inspection cycle or can you just keep
carrying it forward if you haven't
driven it more than 5 000 miles in 10
years or you're not required to go in
for an inspection
thank you representative that is another
excellent question and so the the wheels
are turning here
um that raises an excellent question
that I don't know if that needs to be in
statute or perhaps it should be uh in
terms of you know uh how often would
would this uh
you know this 5 000 mile rule apply
um I will we'll get you an answer uh
today on that
um and again as I said before uh now
that this committee owns this measure uh
when you think it's been some excellent
questions and there will probably be
more as you look at this and discuss it
in this hearing and Beyond so if you
flag you know questions like that again
it's something that the committee
certainly could add to the language and
uh
and address that excellent question
representative I actually have a
question regarding antique Vehicles do
all of them have odometers
thank you for your question I
I am sure that the real antiques that go
way back uh before odometers were
invented did not have odometers and that
as to when odometers came into being a
I'm going to guess some of the duty
experts in this committee maybe know
that
but again that's a that's a great
question we'll get that answer and the
gentleman to follow me may have that and
like I said if he doesn't have that we
will find that out today
thank you any other questions from the
committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair do you know how many
antique Vehicles New Hampshire has
uh another great question and my batting
average on answering these questions is
not great and I no I don't know how many
there are but uh I I am curious and
these are things that we will find out
uh today uh excellent question
representative Jones
foreign
antique Vehicles do they have their own
emission standards that aren't the same
as temporary vehicles
thank you for your question that's an
interesting question I actually was
speaking to uh the gentleman is going to
follow me here uh who actually
originally from Connecticut and I spent
a lot of time in California so the
question with regard to Mission
standards varies from state to state
in terms of uh New Hampshire again I'm
not sure what the latest is but
that does raise another question in
terms of the state like if someone
moves to New Hampshire which uh the
gentleman to follow me moved here from
Connecticut
with in fact you know we're just talking
about this
a vehicle that passes an emission uh
requirement in one state uh may have to
change you know what passes in one state
may not pass in another state so uh
again it varies from state to state
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
recognizes uh Paul Messier who's in
support of the bill
good afternoon
um
yes I'm I'm the gentleman uh Mike was
talking about uh I just I moved I moved
into new New Hampshire
um a few years years ago
um
and um one of the things I've I've
experienced with not only trouble
getting the car prop properly in
inspected but
um I don't like running my cars when
there's sand and salt on on the road I
volunteer uh at the at the at New
England at noon at the New England at
the New England racing racing Museum up
by this up by in Loudon by the by the by
the track and I have worked at a lot of
car shows gotten gotten involved with a
lot of car people in the state one of
the questions was how many antique cars
we have in the state I really don't
quantify that however
I can honestly say since I've been in
New Hampshire I I have learned of three
car collections that have excess of 100
cars
yeah
um and um the one of the ones in Sanborn
to Borton
he's got a 1926 Rolls-Royce Phantom
um yes it does have a an odometer on it
uh but he actually this guy is very is
very very very wealthy and he's got his
own private private his only private
mechanic that is certified by state to
throw put the inspection sticker on the
on the car
um because you know he says it's it's
impossible to find someone that's first
aversal enough that knows what to look
for you know old old old cars
uh so you know my first part of this
bill was to move the inspection from
April to may just so we're not forced to
take the cars out on the sand and salt
uh I brought mine in May of last year
the garage had a line after me of all
antique cars and this was during the
month of May so we were already expired
uh the second part of the bill the 5 000
mile
um
actually
um the way I envisioned that working is
the mileage when they put a sticker on
the windshield of that's past their
mileage is on the sticker so if a and
this is the this would be the only onus
on let's say a
you're gonna end up driving that car
right now it goes by the by the color
you get flagged by the color if I think
the police look for the colors thicker
is going to make their job one more step
they're going to say well gee that
color's expired he stops looks at the
car uh looks at the tag on the
windshield looks at the miles let's say
50 000 and you only get 51 000 on the
odometer he's got to ask the as a driver
that's the only
issue I see with the with the mileage my
my I'm I feel I'm being conservative on
the 5 000 Miles because
um
the you know a car is the parts that
gonna need an inspection to make sure
they were they're still mechanically
sound where during during the course of
driving driving a car
these antique cars are typically only
driven the summer months a few a few
hundred hundred miles up at the most
probably so it would take and I'm once
you go over that 5 000 mile threshold
the car would have to be that car would
have to be in
inspected so basically you kind of
expand the time limit from a time limit
to a to a mileage limit uh with that
with that with that part part of the law
and um
so you know that's all I'm trying to do
there is trying to give all these you
know people with classic cars hey
instead of going every two every two
years right now uh antique car is any
car that's over over 25
any car over 25 years old the two-year
inspection is a car over 40 40 years so
between 25 and 40 you have to have it
inspected every every year by the way I
understand what the law is
um emissions expires at after 20 after
20 20 years and that's been most of the
states that I've looked at uh emissions
are only checked at at the in the for
the first 20 years of the of the car age
um I think I hit on most of the
questions you're asking Mike Mike there
um
my further point on the 5 000 mile limit
uh and talking some some people that um
uh Mike didn't put in this bill but I'd
like to like to like like the committee
to think about
uh I have have run into a lot of people
that now work from home they put very
few miles on their on their personal car
and even me myself I have a 2004 van
that I don't use very very often when I
brought it in for inspection last year
the guy goes you've only put 3 000 miles
on the car
and it's like yeah I have seven vehicles
I can drive in the summertime I'd like
to take out the out of my 66 Mustang I
don't like to pick out my 2004 van and
uh he just thought it was a complete
waste of time to even even inspect it
that was his his exact words and I
basically felt like I paid forty dollars
for a sticker on the windshield and it
really didn't didn't look at it at any
anything but he had he had looked at it
over good a year year be before so this
mileage limit I'd like to
like the board to you know the the
consider maybe extend to all the other
people that work from home and that kind
of and retired people is they don't put
a lot of miles on them on the car
um I think I hit most of my points my
notes any questions for me
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Staub
thank you Mr chairman is it possible for
an antique vehicle to fail for reasons
that are independent of how many miles
are on the car
yes it is I mean especially if a car is
driven a lot in the winter time in in
New Hampshire
um you know use
um use salt to salt on the roads and um
and I'm gonna say new
Hampshire is I'm going to say
um by what I've read not that I've seen
it enforced basically is looking for any
rust on the vehicle and by what I've
read any you're not supposed to have any
rust holes in outer body or the frame
however
um I still see a lot of cars on the road
uh with either holes or what's about to
come whole so depending on on the
maintenance of vehicle vehicle you could
have a fairly new vehicle I just talked
to someone a week
uh I don't know how many miles we're on
this car but I just talked to someone at
the Museum last weekend that had a 2014
Chevy that just failed because of of the
of the rust and uh so it's very possible
but here again so yeah you could have an
everyday driver that could fail on on
salt but
and this is this brings up a point of
what's going on with the inspections
also from my experience and my personal
experience on looking at a couple of
vehicles
I've seen Vehicles get passed along
and all sudden and actually sold that
small used car dealer dealer dealerships
and then the buyer a year later finds
out it failed because there's a big hole
in the frame that the other dealership
through a pass sticker on you know on
unfortunately there's always a few bad
apples but put it that way and in this
case there was a you know um and I have
a picture if you'd like to see it there
was a big hole in the frame that the
dealership had tarred over and sold it
and now this this guy paid five thousand
dollars for a car that's basically junk
um and um so you know this kind of stuff
stuff does does happen there's no
perfect system out there and to me it
should be flagged
in the car in either in the Carfax in
this particular
um vehicle I actually ran the Carfax out
of curiosity there's no Flags in the
Carfax or the vehicle inspection reports
that it had a rust problem
Russ that rust that disables a car from
being driven on the road does not happen
in a year does not happen in two or
three years it's it's at least a three
to four year thing where it's going to
get worse and worse and worse where I
feel as the mechanics responsibility to
put a notation there should be a flag on
that car that there's a problem coming
and and there isn't so I can honestly
say going from a state of of Connecticut
which has no inspections to appear I
don't see any differences
thank you any further questions
representative
we've had thank you Mr chairman thank
you again for taking my question um
we've had testimony in the past that
inspections tend to look at where items
um and they're not always dependent on
mileage it can
rubber items like brake lines windshield
wipers tires uh rubber seals can all
deteriorate over time brake line breaks
can seize up over time
how do you prevent somebody who's maybe
stored their car for two years hasn't
driven it a single mile from
assuming that the car is just in great
condition because I've interpreted into
you know two years and I can just take
it out on the road because I don't
legally need it
that's why on the mile you know on the
on the mileage limit I kept it kept it
fairly low I think 5 000 miles is very
very low
um you know and as opposed to like a ten
a ten Thousand Mile limit but you know
here again uh if we're looking at a car
uh of
and antique car is not driven very very
often uh if it's kept out and I doubt if
anybody when the antique car keeps it
out outside those rubber components it's
it's the weather that that gets to gets
to them and the UV rays from the from
the from the Sun
um you know I uh a day a a daily a car
that's that's
daily driven it's kind of is going to go
over the 5 000 mile mile limit for
uh fairly quickly I think so you're
you're back to doing doing doing the
inspection uh but you know here again
like I said I don't
I've come from a state without any in
inspections and I don't see I don't I
didn't see any more problems down there
than we do we than we have than we have
here so that's where I'm I'm kind of on
the fence level you know what is the
goal of inspection I mean I think the
first primary goal is to keep our roads
safe but there's a lot of states without
inspections that I don't think have any
Better or Worse safety as they uh than
the city and then the state of New
Hampshire
so at least from at least from my my
experience
any other questions
representative Sinclair
thank you you answered one of my
questions as to emphasize that you come
from a state with no inspections at all
although they do have emission control
they have emissions for the first 20
years of the car's life every two years
they check emissions they have they have
they used to have tailpipe emissions
where they actually put the probe in the
tailpipe which to me is a true test okay
and one follow-up if I may well thank
you um and would you not agree that the
the owners of I would probably say close
to 100 percent of the people that loved
dearly these antique vehicles of theirs
pay very close attention to all the
mechanical components of the vehicle
correct thank you
um if you
you're interested
I have
pictures of what of two of the two of
them the bottom of two or two of my my
cars
I mean the bottom of my car is as clean
as the top side of my cars and that's
why I do not want to take them on a
salty salty roads and I'm also
when I talk about getting a qualified
mechanic
um I've heard some horror stories of
people in a mustang club bringing them
to a garage and
um the mechanic had no looking at a 66
Mustang and he didn't understand the
mechanics behind the 66 Mustang you know
you get a 25 year old
kid that's working for a garage with the
certification that they can inspect and
he's never seen a 1960 series car
and uh nor even know how to start it
any further questions
not seeing it on thank you
tier recognizes uh Dan Bennett who is
not taking a position on the bill and
he's asking for three minutes
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
uh Dan Bennett New Hampshire Automobile
Dealers Association based on a couple of
things that I've heard I may take a
slight bit more than three minutes just
to be able to respond to some of the
committee's questions and accurately
answer them so thank you for your time
again Dan Bennett New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association
um we are here on HB 54 in the fact that
we both support and oppose the bill as
there are two different sections of it
two distinctly different sections of the
bill primarily to begin with the move uh
based on the uh the month of inspection
is entirely reasonable based on weather
and we we do in fact support that
provision this is only further
emphasized or coupled with the fact that
we do have the billability in New
Hampshire to inspect Vehicles four
months earlier than their required
inspection date so if someone really did
have a parade to tend to uh in April or
the months prior they would be able to
inspect uh even four months before that
may date so an entirely logical
adjustment um
the second section of the bill however
that we do in fact oppose is the 5000 uh
every two years or 2500 per year
inspection exemption
um antiques
um are not intended for daily use so
2500 miles is a lot of parades that I
can see so that number the starting
point for that number I'm not even
really sure
um where that came from
um it's our opinion that this bill will
basically give a blanket pass for
anything
um registered as an antique
to just not seek or require a safety
inspection
representative Sinclair I agree with you
that are there are many and hundreds of
antique owners some in this room who are
passionate about their vehicles maintain
them immaculately it is their projects
and pride and joy and hobby however
there are also folks that use the
antique exemption as a way to seek out
cheaper registration fees and that is
their motivation so it's not all car
lovers it's also sometimes an
opportunity to find a reduction in fees
so there are we're concerned about
um those folks
the other component that I'll mention is
just strict enforcement
so mileage is not tracked at point of
registration with your town clerk so if
the inspection goes away who in fact is
going to be the enforcer of that 5 000
mile or 2500 per year is State Police
going to be required to pull over every
vehicle that has an antique
and then how do they in fact track that
is the town clerk going to serve as the
enforcement agent to say well you did
499 or you did five zero zero three now
you got to go get inspection come back
to me then I'll give you your
registration so that's problematic there
in the enforcement
um
uh as mentioned there is a case that um
that like representing Sinclair
mentioned there's folks that keep those
Vehicles Immaculate
um however there are folks that the
vehicles do in fact just sit
um and when older vehicles just sit bad
things happen dry rot on tires hoses uh
leaking leaking gaskets can happen so um
in some cases
um not all but in some the inspections
are necessary
um you know uh step vehicles that sit
I'm sure some of you have all seen
hopefully not been witnessed to
um with vehicles that sit tons sometimes
we have rodents that make a home
and the Damage that they do can do
inside a vehicle so
um just moving on to some of the
questions that I heard
um
you know about you choose to register as
an antique it's not a requirement you
choose to once the vehicle reaches that
that
um 25 year mark
um again I don't know what the I don't
know what the the mileage check will be
the rules do in fact lay out the
specifics for antique inspections I
heard those questions uh some some of
the same rules apply to everything but
you cannot OBD2 test so you visually you
visually
inspect the emission system make sure
the canister is still there certain
things so there still are a different
set of inspection requirements for
antiques
as far as how many antiques this applies
to the DMV can certainly run your report
as to how many registered antiques there
are in the state down to the number
um
how many it would apply to is really
kind of arbitrary or I guess we would
just race to that number because once
this goes into place none of them would
really be inspected because there's no
check on it a case could be made I
believe
um
rust I heard a lot about rust rust is
allowed in the state of New Hampshire
two sessions ago you actually made a
legislative effort to weaken the rust
rules to afford consumers flexibility on
their vehicle as it relates to rust so
rust is in fact allowed however not If
it creates an unsafe situation sharp or
protruding edges fumes that enter a
passenger cabin those are some of the
cases where rust is in fact disallowed
so
um I Heard the common two comments real
quick
um
you know I heard about Bad actors it's
correct there are Bad actors there's bad
inspectors uh there's there's bad
doctors lawyers contractors
um I'm thankful that we live in a state
that has checks on those
um we have the Attorney General's office
we have the autocap program that I
mentioned to you before we have State
Police Troop G in their inspection and
enforcement unit so if there are in fact
Bad actors we have
um strict controls on enforcement
um
I heard comments about uh things linked
to Carfax New Hampshire vehicle
inspections have nothing to do with
Carfax CARFAX is an industry it's an
insurance industry program that's
related to accidents and injuries that
were reportable it has nothing or no tie
to New Hampshire State safety
inspections
um so uh with that being said just a
couple comments that I had for you all
and then a couple responses to some of
the questions I hope they were helpful I
hope they were informative
um and I can be of assistance if there's
any others that you may have
thank you Mr Bennett any questions from
the committee
let me get the question
representative Staub
um the question that I have is that this
bill would um exempt Vehicles which are
40 years old or older which means that
any vehicle manufactured before 1982
would be eligible for this and we've
heard that I'm sorry to go on but we've
heard that most antique vehicles are are
kept in pristine condition what
how many vehicles
um
that are of that age of the like 1980
1982 might still be on the road
um regularly I'm just um
you know I'm thinking about pickup
trucks and stuff that people keep for a
long time is there any way to find that
out thank you yeah so I'll do my best to
answer it um so one DMV does have the
registration date on on uh on antique
Vehicles so they would be the ones that
would be able to down to the vehicle
Supply you that however antique Vehicles
has two categories it's 40 plus and 25
to 40. at 25 you are in fact eligible
for an antique registration it just
depends on your inspection cycle whether
you have every year or every other year
the average vehicle uh on the road these
days is over 12 years so
um you know vehicles have been
manufactured over the past years in
higher quality to last much much longer
so it's not uncommon to see that 25-year
vehicle
thank you
representative vayu
thank you Mr chairman
um it's it's possible to get it
inspected up to four months prior to
your date is it if you if it's April and
you don't want to take it out can you
have it done in May or is April you know
April 30th the cut off
can you have it done in May and
essentially get an 11 month inspection
or yeah representative thank you for
your question you're actually allowed 10
months excuse me 10 days into the next
month so if you forgot your birthday was
April you realize it on May 3rd you have
a 10-day window to get down there at an
inspection station to drive it without
being guilty of driving an unsafe motor
vehicle on the road
there are some unique exemptions I don't
know how often they're used and they
have to be approved by the DMV I believe
the director specifically to have a
vehicle Drive outside of its inspection
cycle
you come into the inheritance of
um you know your grandfather's Mustang
that's been in the barn after you
determine that it's roadworthiness you
just need to get it to the inspection
station you can get a 24-hour exemption
it's a very narrow provision of the law
I don't know how frequently it's
actually used or it's actually been
issued but four months prior ten days
into the next month is the the rude
answer to your question
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chair I I'm curious to know
from you if the DMV is on the list of
pink cards that we got
no all right so with that understanding
is it possible for this committee to
learn from the DMV the numbers of
antique vehicles on the road the numbers
of antique vehicles that may have failed
inspection because that would have a
bearing on our our discussions
yes we can get that okay thank you
representative Sinclair
thank you we have a
added thing here that the fiscal impact
of this would be less than ten thousand
dollars in each of the fiscal years
2023-26. do you have any idea what if
this was to pass
what the uh impact would be for the
car dealers garages that do inspect
vehicles
I have no idea uh the fee for motor
vehicle inspections is free market based
and the state does not set a cap or a
limit so it is up to the business to
make the decision as to what their
inspection fee would be so there's no
straight calculation I could do where I
could take 10 000 Vehicles times 199 and
give you a number because it's like I
said it's free market based the shop
charges what it charges
follow up
have you heard from uh I'm pretty sure
you represent that group of businesses
have you heard of that they're against
this or they're
no support or any concern at all yeah uh
so obviously like any trade Association
like most trade associations we have a
legislative committee that gets together
that looks at bills of priority this
bill was flagged for us and the exact
opinion that I gave to you all which is
we support the first half but not the
second half is our is our opinion on it
and they are those ins yeah they are
those inspection stations repairs
independent franchise that are
represented the folks who are in the
trenches day to day and that's where
they came down on this
representative C
thank you Mr chairman uh just to clarify
you had said you were in favor of the
first part and not the second part
however the part regarding moving to the
month of May from April is actually the
second part
that starts on line seven
oh great catch representative see sorry
about that I did it in the wrong order
but I think everybody gets the concept
the date move is okay the the mileage
exemption we're not supportive of thank
you thank you
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
so if I understand the way this is
written right now I'm just trying to
figure this out if if I had an antique
car and I drove it 500 miles one year
500 the next
and I'm supposed to get inspected every
two years or could I do another 500 500
is this a rolling two years or rolling 5
000 anybody
can update me on that
uh yeah so
um I'll give it a chance I'm not sure I
entirely understand your line of
questioning but inspections are done on
a annual calendar it is not a cumulative
mileage number it's not when you reach X
you must do y it's a from here to here
inspections are January to January June
to June based on what your birth month
is
follow-up thank you Mr I'm just looking
at it says it shall not be required
all right and and that's what I'm
getting at the if the B if the vehicle
has been driven less than 5 000 miles in
the preceding two years
so I'm just yeah so I I think I see
where you're going so I guess a case
could be made where there would be a
scenario where you could drive 500 miles
in year one because it was a really
rainy parade season and then the next
year we had beautiful weather and you
slammed on
you know another 5 000 miles in year two
you'd be at fifty five hundred
hence this wouldn't this exemption would
not apply because at the end of your
two-year cycle that's I'm just saying
that's what I believe is being proposed
here on paper at the end of that
two-year cycle you'd be above the 5 000
Mark so you'd be back into the current
existing system
um is I believe how this would function
but
as I hope we never get there so
representative Sykes
so I'm just I'm not expecting an answer
from you uh Mr Bennett but thank you
conversely one could drive 500 miles a
year
and in 10 years they'll only finally
meet the 5 000 mile requirement does
this bill envision
um requiring the inspection every two
years regardless of mileage I don't know
that I read that into this
I'll answer it anyway my read is that
you would never have the vehicle
inspected ever
thank you
any further questions for the committee
thank you Mr Bennett thank you
we do have someone here from the DMV
that might be able to answer
representative Sykes questions
Jeff hyperdig would you like to maybe
follow up on the question that
representative Sykes had
since you kind of waved at me
good afternoon Mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the record my name is
Jeff orbernank and I am here
representing Division of Motor Vehicles
today I do have somebody looking up the
numbers that you're looking for for
antiques right now the number of
antiques registered I should have in a
few minutes but the number that have
failed I'm going to get the last couple
years worth of data that may take a few
hours to get but we'll get those numbers
for you
okay thank you
and if you can fill out a pink card it
would be great absolutely
representative Sinclair when you
when you get the list of what they
failed for can you break that down for
instance did they fail for
tires with not enough tread did they
fail for bad breaks did they fail for
body Rod frames that's because they're
very really different uh really serious
offenses that need to be really looked
at versus wipers
or something like that is that possible
um I'll tell you that when I get the
report uh but the more detail I have
then I mean I'll share everything we
have so if I get the detailed report I
can I can pass that along as well I'll
get it out to the chair and you can
distribute
any other questions
thank you
chair now like to recognize Lieutenant
Jay O'Leary
who does not have a position on the bill
and he's asked for five minutes
good afternoon Mr chair members of
committee Lieutenant Jay O'Leary from
New Hampshire State Police Troop G
as you'll find in most of the testimony
I'll be providing today it will be
educational and I will not have a
position however I do want to just um
point out a couple of things our
concerns from an enforcement end on on
this uh proposed bill
in looking at essentially how a law
enforcement officer would be able to
ensure that a vehicle is in compliance
with the the law the way that it would
be written at the time in which the
vehicle is inspected
it would uh the mileage would be
documented it's not as Dana mentioned
it's not documented the town hall when
it's registered so it would be
documented when it's inspected that
sticker then gets displayed on the
vehicle itself so in theory when the law
enforcement officer stops the vehicle
the the uh they would be able to
identify the mileage based on the
sticker that's on the car
the what becomes problematic with that
approach is essentially the Violator
the driver of the vehicle isn't
necessarily in violation of the law if
it's written this way because if they do
have that 5 000 mile exemption in theory
they could display an expired inspection
sticker so a law enforcement officer
coming the other way looks at the car
sees that it's expired stops the vehicle
on that premise and finds that in
reviewing the mileage and the mileage
that's on the on the motor vehicle
itself that they're within that
exemption what's problematic about that
is the preface of the stop so our
concern would be how can we track the
mileage where we wouldn't be
um you know providing a a an issue with
the public and having to unnecessarily
conduct motor vehicle stops for somebody
that's in compliance with the law
the second part that is
of note would be that one of the items
of inspection on these vehicles is the
odometer so if the odometer is not an
item that's inspected we're not really
sure if it's functioning so potentially
it could travel uh well over 5000 miles
with a broken odometer and law
enforcement would have no way of knowing
that since the vehicle was not you know
recently inspected
as far as the 5000 mile
exemption the confusion I think lies in
the enforcement portion being does the
new buyer of the vehicle then have to
have the car inspected does the 5000
miles now just roll over to the new
purchaser of the vehicle and what that
looks like so those are just on the
enforcement issues that we're concerned
with
any questions from the committee
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair uh I just I think I
know the answer but I just want to hear
it from you if you if a trooper stops a
vehicle whether it's for a sticker that
may be expired or anything else is it
not a fact that the trooper does do a
once-over of every vehicle to look for
any obvious signs of unsafe tires or a
headlight out or a brake light out or
things like that no matter what the
sticker says no matter what year the
vehicle is uh I mean it could happen you
know essentially that could be the
reason why the vehicle is stopped to
begin with because you do see such a
violation like headlight out or so on
and so forth so for every stop no but it
is a reason and once in a while that we
would do that okay thank you for your
question
any other questions representative of AU
thank you for thank you Mr chairman um
what if you have a situation where
at the two-year Mark April
you had driven only 4 900 miles so
you're no longer you don't you're not
required to inspect that year
but by the end of May you're at over
5000 how does the police officer know
that you were under the 5 000 in April
and you don't have to get it inspected
for another two years yeah
representative that's a that's a very
good question and that's that's
essentially what our uh you know our
problem is with the way that it's
written we're concerned that we're not
going to be able to determine that
any further questions from the committee
not seeing it on thank you lieutenant
that's the last list of speakers I've
had is anybody else that like to speak
on HB 54.
not seeing any
I'm going to close the hearing on HP 54.
next bill we're going to be taking up is
HB 111 in a few minutes
good job
laughs
there's really only one but there are
other people
I will hopefully keep it simple
oh that's right
okay I like to open the open the public
hearing on HB uh 111 establishing a
committee to study electrical vehicle
charging for residential renters and the
chair recognizes representative Schultz
thank you Mr chair Transportation
committee members it's an honor to be
here
um
I'm here because I actually experienced
this issue and and talking to others I
realize this is a big question mark that
maybe we as study commit committee
members can
um
address in a way that maybe won't cost
anything from the government Etc so
um I am a rep here in Concord
I did all my research because I had very
tight criteria to purchase a car
having my godfather works for uh Ford
Motor Company building cars so it had to
be a UAW car
I had Consumer Reports it had to have a
good rating and I wanted an electric car
or hybrid
so that got me down to the Ford Fusion
of 20 2017 because I also am paying off
student loans so it wasn't going to be a
new car
so after lots of research on that and
realizing we would need to have a place
to plug it in where we live we live at a
complex that has over 400 units
and all the parking spaces to match that
and in in my district alone there are
three other complexes that are roughly
if you add them together about that many
renders and none of them and as far as I
know
uh none in Concord have any sort of
ability for charging we were willing to
pay for it ourselves we approached the
landlord in that way and we were willing
to leave behind whatever infrastructure
we had with that including connecting it
to our utilities because we do pay our
own electric bills separate from the
other renters and we also were paying
for a parking space that was covered and
had its own uh electric plug-in for
everybody that had one of those
um the answer I got from the landlord
and I think they're pretty good
landlords was hmm no one's ever asked
for this
um let me ask so then the management
company company came back and said could
you write a memo
and the answer I had at the time as well
we're about to lose this deal on this
great car and so we bought a different a
non um
hybrid 2017 Ford Fusion but knowing that
this will continue to be an issue I
thought the next time I could file a
bill this would be a great study to have
um and get ahead of questions that a lot
of hotels rest stops lots of other areas
of the state have already thought this
through and have charging stations and
is more and more demand
and I suspect
uh many to most cars if not all cars at
a certain age will be electric so this
is something that I think would be
helpful to
the community in general it could be
helpful to small
to people who have
one or two apartments to rent
potentially it gets ahead of an issue
that is coming regardless of your view
of fossil fuels and electric cars
um that is as simple as it gets so
um to bring together the stakeholders uh
you know utility companies if that's
something that is needed certainly
there are groups that Lobby for tenants
and for landlords and you guys are the
expert on transportation and cars not me
so I definitely would welcome other
stakeholders that would be helpful and
just to have the Chipotle pull together
in a bipartisan way to have the
conversation
and then that memo can get written and
be helpful to uh subsequent renters and
landlords
who are facing this issue
that plain and simple
thank you representative any questions
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
absolutely nice to see you again
um I'm I'm curious uh if you are aware
of any of the Senate three members that
you list here would who would be willing
to serve on such a committee it's funny
you mention that because I paid so much
attention to some my other bills I filed
all of the bills I'm sponsoring at once
at midnight the day we could file and I
didn't there definitely you will hear
other people that are interested I'm
certain I can get three uh folks
um I know of at least two Democrats I
could get and I would love to hear any
Republican suggestions on the right
maybe a transportation Committee Member
in the Senate
follow up thank you uh thank you Mr
chair um I'm wondering if
um you explored I I think we have how
many electric vehicle
um committees already established are
are these issues that are coming up in
any of those are you aware of
I don't believe so and honestly I
thought this bill would go to
um the committee that handles landlord
and tenant law but that is a wisdom
that's above my pay grade
any other further questions from the
committee representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman representative
Schultz it's your intention that this
would be a committee not a commission
and the difference being
committee is just members of the house
or Senate and that they can ask experts
to come in but the experts would not be
late called out as part of the study
bill absolutely I saw this more as a
formalization of Step Above ad hoc
committee that anybody could that is a
rep could set up but to have that
formalization would be to include the
bipartisan discussion and not just you
know
not just on a whim so but not as big as
a commission absolutely
representative C
thank you Mr chairman uh just uh
curiosity and you may not know the
answer uh do the various car brands have
compatible connectors or uh do they just
use 120 volts ac
the charging stations at malls and stuff
tend to have a special connector I think
is just for one brand of car
similar to cell phones I will say I know
that this issue is being debated among
both consumers and the companies
I hope that there will be some
standardization but you know there's a
lot of pieces of this that I think need
to be considered that I'll just say
that's a debate that's bigger than this
study commission or study committee
should not use the word commission I
just said the word commission
um that this very modest study committee
would not be probably settling any
debates around hookups I do know though
that there are programs some sponsored
by companies some by maybe the federal
government there used to be anyway
programs to assist people to have
hookups I don't know the answer to those
questions right now though and I think
that's great to include on the agenda
for this modest study committee
just for uh kind of just for the
committee we heard testimony and lost
term regarding this specific question
regarding connectors with the different
electrical vehicles and they're all
different
here's what I do know if you don't mind
Mr chair
um I do know from my research that I
there are there are hookups for that car
that I was purchasing and I assume for
the other types of electric vehicles as
well that would work well with what my
apartment complex had at our covered
parking spaces given that we each had an
electrical outlet that was standard it
is adaptable as far as I understand it
that the equipment overall for
individual homeowner use is fairly uh
user friendly and I don't think it's
that expensive either so there are types
that become more permanent like if it
were instead of a covered parking space
it would the types that would be for
example solar based that would be at the
non-covered spots that are not reserved
at least in my complex some have
reserved parking spaces at complexes per
apartments
that also would be CR great to have and
those would be more permanent and work
with the utilities as well but to some
degree some of them would
um this is an evolving thing but no
doubt I'm not the first resident in
Concord that rents
to want to have this
any further questions from the committee
representative Rambo
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Schultz uh this morning
during our committee orientation and we
had Department introductions the dot was
talking a little bit about the New
Hampshire Transportation Council which I
admit I'm I'm still learning about and
it talked about being opportunities that
the council can serve in lieu of
legislative study committees or
commissions for setting emerging
Technologies and modes to improve
Transportation uh going forward I'm just
wondering
if there is overlap or if there's a way
within with the transportation Council
be useful or helpful in in this scenario
I would say so I think the what would be
missing in that conversation and why
having a a um modest not quite too
formal study committee would be that we
could more formally invite both the
landlords and tenants in a way that may
be just speaking to our state's
Department
maybe they would do that I don't know
but it also would ensure the bipartisan
discussion because I think
um having diversity of thought is only
going to make the end product more
user-friendly
and what this study committee comes to
recommend
thank you
any further questions from the committee
Representatives Jones
two questions find me Mr chairman uh
first um thank you for coming
representative
um you mentioned the uh the 110 I
believe there's two forms there's the
fast to slow charge which is a 110 which
takes about eight hours and the fast
charge I believe is a 220 which takes
about two hours so that's something that
this committee should look at and uh the
other question
um is uh are you aware that the
manufacturers
are because they want to sell EV cars
they're offering the free infrastructure
in public places I haven't heard of it
yet in private places but it's something
you might want to look into
it would save you some money in New York
that committee could sort of look into
it absolutely and that was something
that I was aware of as well as I knew at
least when I bought this car two years
ago when we were in the middle of covid
there it was a part of I think one of
the stimulus packages too
um look at certain incentives
uh to be made available to places that
might have uh electric vehicles in their
parking lots and I think that
um
those are good points for that and I
think
um I mean there's just a number of
pieces we need to get ahead of on this
and honestly even after the study report
is written I'm sure that it will evolve
in a much bigger way than our modest
study committee will need to address
any further questions from the committee
not seeing none thank you representative
thank you so much
at this point that you're like to
recognize representative Chris Schultz
that was you okay well
never mind I've never had the game
the chair now recognizes representative
Rebecca
Williams
Mick Williams
who supports the bill and is requested
five minutes
thank you chair Walsh members of the
committee my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams and for the record I
represent South Concord you're actually
part of my district right now so welcome
to South Concord
um I am a member of the science
technology and energy committee so I
felt that it was important to come in
front of you and just have a quick
discussion about the future of EVs and
where we're headed as a state
um specifically 30 percent of New
Hampshire rents
so one out of three look around this
room one in three is a renter
what that means is eventually they'll
probably be driving either a hybrid or
an EV in the future and so we need to do
something to set the groundwork now to
figure out how that's going to work
um certainly in my district I have folks
who are in all kinds of interesting
renting situations some of them are in
duplexes and some of them are in
apartment buildings with like what
representative Schultz talks about 400
people with outdoor parking and some of
it covered some of it not so we have
some interesting scenarios that are
worth considering and putting a plan
together for what does that look like to
enable EV charging for these different
types of renting situations also we have
Urban versus Rural right so for someone
who's a rural renter and is off a dirt
road and you know old farmhouse and
probably doesn't really have all that
reliable electricity that may be a very
different scenario for a tenant than
somebody who's in an urban situation
with 400 cars on a lot next to a big
apartment apartment building
um so I think that this bill brings up a
lot of interesting questions about what
does that look like and I think it would
be a really great opportunity to have
the discussion with landlords and
tenants about what would be the best way
for us to approach this so that it's not
an ad hoc approach and so that there's
at least some guidance
for what happens next as the industry is
changing so just as an example
um we've had a really interesting study
going on at UNH related to the Nissan
Leaf which is I believe right now the
only vehicle but there are more coming
which you can both charge with your EV
charging station and also you can plug
in and recharge back into the grid so if
you're in a renting situation let's say
you're a college student and you drive a
Nissan Leaf
and you want to plug it in and charge it
probably have it charge at two in the
morning when it's super cheap to charge
but also let's say you're in class from
5 to 8 pm and that's when it's actually
a really good time for you to charge
back into the grid because you would be
getting credits for peak time this is an
interesting opportunity to make it
somewhat lucrative or at least reduce
your electric bill by using your car as
a battery with your grid and the New
Hampshire co-op is doing that now with
this Nissan Leaf model expect this to
roll out with other utilities at some
point but I just want you to have a
sense of the way the industry is going
and how this could be really interesting
it would be good to talk about it so
with that I'm having to take some
questions
any questions from the committee
representative O'Hara
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um isn't this something the free market
could clear up as in the more electric
vehicles that are in the state landlords
are going to want to add that feature to
be able to either increase rent or
attract more applicants
I think the free market question is a
little bit
um like I could ask pre-market about
anything really yeah the free market
impacts our lives every day but when
we're talking about making a plan for
how landlords could Implement across the
state I think it makes sense for us to
come together and make a consensus for
best practices and publish a report
saying these are our best practice
recommendations it doesn't impact the
free market per se right the free market
is going to do what the free market is
going to do but we're providing some
guidance that says it probably makes
sense to provide a variety of different
Chargers since we know that Teslas are
their own special charger and a certain
percentage might need Tesla Chargers but
the approach for installing a Tesla
charger for renters is probably going to
be different than installing for a 220
or 110 more standard charger and there
are more coming out on the market so
obviously that's a different discussion
but something where we could then as the
House of Representatives have some
recommendations have some guidance I
think a committee that's looking at that
makes sense so really the free market is
not really the question I think the real
question is what can we come up with
together as a team that are the
questions and then what can we come up
with as guidance that will help people
make good decisions they may not choose
to listen to it but there's an option
that a group of smart people got
together had really smart people testify
about it and came up with
recommendations
any further questions from the committee
representative bayu
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
as this has been going along I've been
coming up with questions in my head but
I've been refraining from asking them
because I'm
these are the things that the committee
would probably
answer
um is is your one of your ideas you know
as a landlord myself I'm thinking this
could be a good way of helping me Laura
and better tenants uh who might stay
longer and appreciate what they have
more
um so but I'm like what kind of
infrastructure would I put in so do you
envision this can it be like one part of
it to be like an FAQ for
landlords to say what what's available
what answer their questions ahead of
time can you know they might want like
the idea of being able to upload back
into the grid when the car is not in use
and
you know reduce the
electric bill or have that option build
that into the infrastructure when they
you know had electrical work done that
kind of thing does that kind of fit your
ideas
so one of the beautiful things about a
study committee is that you really
charge the study committee to come up
with their series of questions their
agenda who they're inviting to testify
it's really open-ended which is great
because a year like this an odd numbered
year that's when you want to ask all
those questions and get all those people
together to put together a really good
bill if you need one at the end of the
study committee to go in the even
numbered year so what you're describing
in terms of inviting landlords to ask
questions absolutely it's an opportunity
for education for anyone who attends the
study committee to learn about the right
questions to ask and also best practices
so you'll have some of these experts I
imagine from UNH showing up and talking
about future of the industry where we're
headed what does that mean to be a good
landlord and provide charging as a perk
for tenants who might stay longer if you
do that so I do think that that's a
piece of it and um you know charging the
committee with coming up with their own
questions gives us great latitude to do
that
any further questions
not seeing any thank you
thank you so much chair
and I'd like to recognize Lucius
bar call Marshall partial who is in
support of the bill and is requested
three minutes
backwards thank you so much for the
record Lucius partial eight and having
driven a Nissan Leaf for a couple of
years uh I want to say the first line of
charging for me in fact most people is
charging it at home
uh you don't want to park your car
downtown and walk
a couple miles home you want it there
when you need it
um my Nissan Leaf there's a question
about what kind of charging devices we
use
in my garage I have the same hookup that
I have in my basement for my dryer a
three prong it's either 1030p or 1430b
the same things you have in your dryer
and when you buy your electric vehicle
usually comes with a cable that you plug
right into there so there's no question
there's no problems with you know
with universality in that case
and lastly I would just say that I think
that this makes good sense because one
of the things that we're all definitely
aware of is the price of electricity
right now and if we can flatten that
curve as my as our former speaker said
if we can flatten the curve of what we
consume and uh most our consumption is
around five o'clock we're not using the
middle of the night if we can do that
through these electric vehicles the end
result has to be if we believe in the
law of supply and demand on a free
market then we would see a reduction in
our electric costs so and three counts I
fully support this bill
and available for questions if you have
thank you any questions from the
committee
not seeing any oh representative Sykes
yeah
um
thank you Mr chairman
so is it correct that at the present
time other than the New Hampshire
cooperative
that except for very specific programs
most of the electric electric supply
companies do not have time to use rates
that is true that would require uh smart
meters and most of our electric
companies would have installed smart
meters I do know there's a bill coming
forward to install
for consumers to be able to install
Smart Meters at their own cost and
they're relatively inexpensive just a
follow-up
follow-up so my presumption is that
again we're just talking about a study
committee here so this is one of the
topics that a study committee could look
into as well yes it could be and it
would also depend upon whether or not
you have a utilities provided or whether
or not each apartment is metered on
their own so
any further questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you
chair now recognizes uh Chris Scotland
who has requested three minutes he has
written a testimony representing cenh
thank you chairman Walsh and members of
the committee my name is Chris goglin
I'm the director of energy transition
with clean energy New Hampshire we're a
non-profit organization with over 130
business members and 34 Municipal
members representing almost 300 000 New
Hampshire citizens with hundreds of
additional individual residents that are
members of our
organization we advance the or we
advocate for the adoption of clean
energy initiatives through a nonpartisan
fact-based lens and we are host to the
drive Electric New Hampshire Coalition
which was formed to support electric
vehicle adoption across the state
New Hampshire sorry I worked for the
state for 15 years it's going to be a
hard habit to get rid of
sorry Becky
um clean energy New Hampshire takes no
position on the bill as written but
offers the following information for
consideration
EVS are more energy and cost efficient
technology
they convert 77 percent of the
electrical and energy they take back
from the grid into moving the car or
vehicle forward where a conventional gas
and diesel engine only converts 17 to 30
percent of the energy stored
to move the vehicle the rest is wasted
as heat this represents a significant
cost savings to EV owners EVS are
currently a small fraction of the
current vehicle Fleet but that is fast
changing in the next decade it is
expected that EVS on the New England
roads will increase by over 30 times
their current values from 50 000 across
all of New England to more than 1.5
million vehicles
this comes as the price for EVS Falls
but also as more and more auto
manufacturers switch over their
platforms to all electric
the cost for EVS are falling will soon
compete with that of gas and electric or
will compete with out of gas and diesel
vehicles it's forecasted by 2024 to 2025
EV prices will reach parity with
existing gas and diesel vehicles meaning
the price that you are shopping for will
be the same regardless of what platform
you are looking at this will increase
as the supply chains improve across the
entire economy
currently most EV charging by New
Hampshire residents is done at home but
not all residents are suitable suitable
and that's one thing that a study
commission may wish to consider this may
not just be about renters in my
neighborhood there are three uh
communities where there are manufactured
homes they may have smaller panels where
they cannot host the 240 volt circuit
that is required for a level two
charging at the house
for my house I have an EV I charge it
for midnight to 8 A.M because I'm a good
guy eventually there will be time of use
rates in fact to answer a previous
question not only does the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op have time of use rates
but Liberty and Unitil have theirs
approved by the puc and are rolling them
out eversource is in the process of
having theirs filed and approved
I'm an eversource customer I don't have
it yet available
but I was able to install My Level 2
charger and
um so it's something that as the
previous uh speaker representative
partial noted it's simply a dryer plug
that we plug into
but with some panels they may not be
able to install this technology or host
this technology and so it's a question
of how do we make this electric vehicles
as they fall in price and as used
vehicle EV Market matures I was actually
able to buy a used EV how do we make it
so that any
resident of New Hampshire is able to
drive these vehicles
and I will pause there
and take any questions you might have
thank you any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you thank you
chair now recognizes Nick Norman
who opposes the bill also has some
written testimony and he represents the
apartment association of New Hampshire
off yeah I appreciate the opportunity to
speak to you thank you very much my name
is Nick Norman
I do represent the department
Association of New Hampshire and the
landlord tenant law legislative
initiative
on the government Affairs chair for the
apartment association of New Hampshire
we have an Outreach of about 3 500
people on our email list that we
communicate to weekly in the landlord
community of landlords across New
Hampshire
so there's a few things that jump out
immediately as
complications with the idea I'm not
opposed to the idea of providing
Chargers
to I to tenants I have a Prius myself
been a Prius owner for years I like
electric vehicles
but I hope that there's no thought that
there would be some kind of a mandate
that property owners have to provide
electrical vehicle charging stations
there could be all kind of complications
complications
um
and I notice in the way this bill is
written that there is nothing that
mandates the requirement to talk to the
stakeholders I've heard a lot of talk
about talking to stakeholders but there
is nothing in this bill that mandates
that at all
and in our experience we've often seen
commissions and committees come up with
things that end up with mandates on
property owners that become very
expensive
and then all of that gets transferred
into increased rents and in our Market
the idea of forcing for further rent
increases is just unfathomable
so let's think about this for a second
the installation cost could be expensive
do we have to put in new electric meters
is the electric service in that
apartment in all apartments you know
we're sufficient
if we're going to make a station from a
building out to the parking lot so now
we have to dig up the ground and install
an underground cable are we digging up a
parking lot
to put in a charging station
or are we just going to end up with a
hundred cables across the parking lot in
a tripping hazard
is the state going to now release this
from liability of tripping hazards from
all these cables all over the place
um
many landlords don't have any tenants
that have electrical vehicles in some
parts of the country particularly maybe
up in the north where it's it's colder
and it is more
you know in the mountains it doesn't
make might not make sense to have
electric vehicles so again I hope that
there's no mandate on across the board
one one size fits all
there's supply issues with new panels
there are Parts issues in this market
that are making the supply chain of
getting new electric meter boxes almost
impossible to
to obtain
so there's there's many many issues with
this and you know who pays for it
who pays for all this cost
could then we open up a situation that
we've made something so convenient that
other people could run up and charge
their vehicle on someone else's station
now someone's stealing electricity
you know how do we handle that
I think there's a lot of questions here
that makes it
unreasonable to think that we're going
to force Property Owners to be putting
in stations across the board in a one
size fits all
so
probably could talk more but I'll be
happy to answer questions
and that that's our main concerns is
totally not thought out at all and I
think that you'll find that there's a
tremendous amount of issues to be
thought out and all of it can be done on
a one by one case by the landlord
talking with tenant and working out
their own special situation and I agree
with what was said over here the
Market's going to take care of this
because people are going to want more
and more to have an option and a
landlord will want to provide that
option
to make their parking apartment more
rentable
but to have an idea that there's going
to be some kind of a mandate there's
going to be one size fits all
and increase all of the rent costs I
think is unreasonable so I I would
prefer not to have the committee at all
it's we appreciate your Insight and um
however this bill is just about creating
the committee I understand and a lot of
the a lot of the topics you brought up
here
is really jumping really ahead this bill
is just really about secreting a
committee
so any any questions from
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair
thank you if you had landlords and
Property Owners on this committee if it
was even possible
how many would you want Helen there
well I'd like it how would they be
chosen
well the apartment association of New
Hampshire could help you choose
landlords but I think you should have
landlords that have a large number of
units like the hundreds complexes that
you've heard talk about and I think
should have some landlords that are in
the middle
maybe 30 to 50 units and you should have
some small landlords on the committee
and the committee should have some form
of balance
what we've seen historically is
committees are created with a
preponderance of tenant advocates
and very little landlord representation
representation
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you
that is the last of the pink cards
um is there anybody else who would like
to speak on HP 111
not seeing any I'm going to close the
hearing on hb11
our next bill is hb132 we'll pick up in
a few minutes
okay being 229 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 132.
and I guess the prime sponsor
representative Newman
and Ray Newman you're going to open this
up together okay
floor is yours welcome thank you good
afternoon everyone on this committee my
name is Sue Newman I'm represent Nashua
Ward 2.
and I serve on the public works and
highways committee
and I'm Ray Newman I'm also a
representative I'm on the Public Works
committee
not Public Works my wife is on the
Public Works community
I'm on criminal justice it's a little
bit more
interesting
okay
just to be
I hope there's no comments we know we
really know where we go up here
um all right house bill 132 relative to
a tire disclosure
generally there's a little history about
pre-owned trailers to pass along to a
buyer
a trailer's Tire age though is something
that is available and really should be
passed along to buyers as they consider
a purchase
the older a trailer's tires are the
higher the risk is for a blowout and or
a deadly accident
for background the origin of this bill
began November 21st 21 in Troutville
Virginia which is about 700 miles from
Nashua maybe some of you have been there
no all right well
we hadn't either until this time we had
left the previous day from Nashua to
visit our children and grandchildren in
North Carolina in Florida over that
Thanksgiving
and the week before that November 15
2021 our new to us used and dealer
inspected travel trailer was made
available for us to begin travel with
so going back to Troutville
while we were peacefully and very
moderately driving along on Interstate
81 South late in the day on that Sunday
in November
we were alerted by a passing motorist
that something was going on with our
trailer
we pulled over we were fortunate to be
on the right hand side of the road and
could get off to the shoulder and we saw
that one of our trailer's tires was
coming apart
the tread had separated from the trayer
I'm sorry the tire and was flapping
steel belts had snapped and were poking
out all over they looked like Tire
whiskers to me
fortunately we were close to an exit and
another motorist helped us get to a
close by filling station parking lot
Troutville as you may imagine is a very
rural area but most importantly we were
able to get off the interstate and we
were grateful that we didn't have nor
cause a highway accident from the blown
tire
just anecdotally when I was on my way up
here I glanced at my phone and I saw a
blurb the NTSB reports that tire
malfunctions contribute to almost 19
000 motor vehicle accident injuries each
year okay and then the date on that was
2022.
the next day with our spare tire on WE
cautiously drove to a tire dealer to get
a new set of tires one of the tire
installers commented about the age of
the tires that we were replacing he said
our trailer tires were eight between
eight and nine years old
foreign
the most common recommendation for
trailer tires replacement is three to
six years
and most buyers don't even think about
the trailer tires
especially if they've fancied up the
side walls made them look good in the
trailer it's in the tire itself
has a lot of Tread On It people don't
think about that and
um
however there can be dry rot inside the
tire you can't see it and it can lead to
Tire failure
in the older the tires are the higher
the risk of of blowout
um most and the other another thing
about trailers is that most Tire
trailers are subject to long periods of
non-use
in less than optimal conditions
so the tires age more rapidly
on than on other vehicles
however and the reason for that is
tires on other vehicles that are in
constant use release compounds that
increase the longevity of the tires
and we passed out some pictures to you
and those are two of the tires that we
brought home with us
and and we used uh just to show you what
the tires look like and and some of the
things how how well they looked when we
uh bought the trailer at the time
and in the pictures we passed out you
see tires from the trailer the picture
show damage of Tire separation and on
the undamaged tire
and uh tire tread on the on the
undamaged tire Separation on the damaged
tire and tire trade on the uh
the undamaged tire and it was it really
really looked good and of course they
put Tire blank on it and whatever but it
was also inspected afterwards with an
inspection and uh
that's another issue another issue for
us but not pertinent to the bill
um
and one of the in the on the tire it
shows the tire code and the vent spews
now the vent spews are the little pieces
of rubber that you can see around your
tire when it's brand new they usually
wear off in a few years on these tires
you the picture that says ven spews you
can see that those little uh Tire
whatever you want to call them event
spreads are still on the tires even
those those tires are it were eight to
nine years old at the time that we got
the trailer
another thing to know is I learned a lot
about what I didn't know about Tire age
there is a there is a code on every Tire
but that code isn't made for consumers
because the the code that you see is
zero three one three so you might think
that's maybe that's January of 2013.
well not really it's the first week of
2013. so the entire industry has put
that code on there mainly for their use
and for the use of Tire Specialists who
who want to look at a tire when my wife
mentioned the we had the tire replaced
the people that replacer said we don't
even service tires that are more than
six years old
so
and you can get it so you can get into
in the later parts of the Year things
like 22 uh
13 which would mean the 22nd week of
2013.
so so that's what I learned about Tire
coding and age of tires but most people
don't even think about that
so
House Bill 132 is structured to put very
little burden on trailer dealers it only
requires that the dealer shall provide
to the buyer a written document
disclosing the age and manufacture date
of all the tires on the trailer
the written discloser shall be delivered
to the buyer before the buyer signs
documents that complete the sale
buyers will no longer need to determine
Tire age themselves the information
provided would allow buyers to factor
Tire age into their calculations as they
go ahead or not with the purchase this
disclosure will help prevent the sale of
trailers that have dangerously old tires
and we hope that there will be positive
consideration for this Bill thank you
excuse me thank you questions from the
committee representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Representatives
um I'm wondering if you considered
having
um uh speed rating mentioned on that
disclosure as well
um
there's there's a a whole series of
speed ratings that the tires are set up
for and I always figure most of the
people driving by me are exceeding
whatever the speed rating is on their
trailer tire anyway but I wondered if
that was something you would consider
adding no I'm not aware of that I would
I think we would have no objection to an
improving amendment that that might be
added for that but that is also on the
tire and it is there and but when you
buy a a tire that's specifically
designed for for trailers
um they uh they have a speed rating but
and I see people exceeding the speed
ratings but we certainly took it into
consideration when we're buying the
spear that we had to have because it
wasn't much fun sitting down at that
bottom of the exit as it was getting
dark
I I would I would just add that for our
particular first time out with this
trailer
and the tires that it had on it we were
exceptionally cautious in driving and
our road speeds I don't think we went
over 65 was top we were generally
between 60 and 65 for the entire trip
um I'll just mention that
any further questions
representative Schultz
my good friends uh have you given any I
think this is great information for the
public to know but have you given any
consideration to reach out to our
federal representative representatives
to perhaps make this a national bill
that every Tire manufactured in this
country or sold in this country has an
actual date that people can understand
when that tire was made
I we have we have not reached out I've
thought about it and
um
previously there was a time previous to
this that I was thinking about Tire age
and whatnot and bills like that
that require something of the tires that
are on cars and stuff like that in in
there is tremendous pushback
from the tire industry about having to
do that or at least for putting I mean I
I think that there should probably be a
maximum of 10 years because
these are only for use this bill only
applies to used trailers resale trailers
and so the the bigger trailer businesses
they sell most of their stuff that are
on new tire and new trailers and
um so it shouldn't do a lot of impact
now I I actually feel had to sign a
bunch of
um small print documents that before I
bought the trailer and if I had had this
kind of information to me it would it
would have at least peaked in my mind
that
that what what are you going to do we
were constantly assured that we would
never put unsafe trailer tires on the
trailer
and we ended up with what happened to us
so I thought that this information would
be easily provided by the by any used
trailer tire dealer without too much
burden on them at all
thank you
what are the questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um one of the questions I have would
this form have the safety standards
spelled out on it because otherwise I
might just grab the form and say oh
that's great information thank you for
providing it and not know the difference
and you know
um
if it is a safety standard would it be
better to put it on the inspection
requirements and then have recourse in
the end if if you are sold one tires
that are
inadequate oh it
thank you for that question
um I looked at it mostly as a disclosure
of what the age the S the the
um almost a an exact estimate of what
the age of the tires is
I I totally understand what you're
saying and I don't disagree with that
but again I didn't want to
um
I was concerned about I was concerned
about what the dealers would be able to
agree to and and I guess I looked at it
that even when we were getting our
trailer
um had we seen something that said your
trailers here's the numbers on them and
they're between eight and nine years old
it would have prompted me to do a little
more research even if I went to a tire
dealer and said what does this mean how
old are my tires they're eight or nine
years old is that good for a trailer I
guess anecdotally again when we were in
Florida this past November we talked to
a professional
trailer mover person he moves RVs boats
whatever needs moving around and I asked
him so how old should travel trailer
tires be he said he didn't he didn't
skip a beat he didn't I don't think he
stopped for a breath he said no more
than five years old he said that's the
bottom line
um
and there are no inspections for
trailers in this state
and so when we said it was inspected
there was an inspection done for us
afterwards that actually had a question
about that on it we didn't
there were issues with the way the
documents that we signed were presented
and so the information on the tire age
even though it was part of the
inspection was not it was it was not
checked they didn't fill it in
so but I do agree this bill only says
exactly
the only requirements it has is what's
in the bill
but if someone wants to put an amendment
on there to improve it to put on speed
ratings
um or I mean it does say that this must
be completed prior to the in in to the
sale so they would get it and have to
sign it but
I I thought that a bill should not have
this those kind of specific details
maybe I'm mistaken but that that would
come into regulations of the people that
that do the license insurer to the
dealer they would determine
I guess what that um what that would be
any other questions from the committee
representative C
thank you Mr chairman
um quick question uh
you specify in here that this has to be
a separate document rather in some part
of some checklist could you elaborate on
that
yeah that's true
um
the experience that we had was there was
there was a presentation of uh
inspection That was supposed to ensure
that everything was in proper working
order when you left
the trailer dealer
and the reason we want this to be
specific maybe I've lost your question
is
well just one more time what what uh the
question had to do is why not have this
as part of a checklist a generalized
checklist instead of having to be a
specific document
well because this I actually did get a
checklist that they were going to use
for the inspection
and it had 156 items on it entire was
one of those little 156 items so I and
most of the things on a trailer other
than the wheels is not dangerous to you
it's not going to flip your trailer over
it's not going to flip your truck over
so we envisioned this
um
disclosure to be by itself
about tires and specifically telling you
the date that how old they are they're
eight-year-old they're eight years old
and using the tire code they can easily
see that and they were January of 2013
or whatever it was
so I we envisioned something that would
stand out to the buyer when he's
flipping through these that says tire
age disclosure but we didn't try to put
that in the bill
for the questions
seeing that I have one uh just a simple
one
um are you 100 sure that the inflation
the tires were inflated correctly
or that you didn't pick up a nail or cut
the tire on a curb
for example
no we check that the inflation was
correct when we left I mean we we
checked that before we go right so but
okay
I think the the the more serious part of
it is is the way they determine the
damage whether the tire is
um
needs to be changed or not by visual
inspection is that you have to have a
certain length of dry rot on the outside
of the tire that's visible and whatever
so so if the outside looks good and the
tread is good the tire is good to go
there's no there's nothing in in at
least even in this was in the inspection
that we had done and it said if you
can't see it on the outside it's good to
go
oh there's another witness I'll ask in
terms of the inspection and the dry rot
did you inspect the tires yourself on
the on the trailer
yeah
we visually I mean the trailer when we
saw it it was parked so trailers I mean
the tires are underneath just like
you would expect them to be
um
when I asked about tires and was told if
it needs tires when we go over it you'll
have new tires before you take it off
the lot okay
looking at the tires visually they
looked fine and I could see there was
plenty of tread that's the amount of the
inspection I guess as to inflation
though I will comment that when we had
to get the spare on we discovered that
the spare
um we anyway that was a whole other
story getting us us doing the US getting
the spare on but we certainly recognize
the importance of inflation and when new
tires were put on I mean we were
watching every step of the way and they
corroborated and confirmed what the
inflation rate was and off we went
and another thing that was kind of
interesting was that
um
when
the interesting thing was that when we
when we uh
got the uh
what's my train of thought
okay I I would
um I guess going back to a previous
question the idea of a disclosure
um to give the buyer information and I
and I recognized that all buyers may not
be aware of what an age should be on a
trailer any utility trailer that they
could be purchasing I would hope though
that the disclosure would encourage them
prompt them to check it out further
somebody separate from a dealer go to a
tire place and say what would this mean
I'm considering buying XYZ the trailers
on it are eight or nine years old would
you do that is that something you would
do so the buyer can get educated as to
how to move forward or negotiate with
the dealer
my thought came back to me the the
people constantly said you're gonna
you're gonna get safe tires they never
mentioned age and they always sent you
back to the representative you were
talking to to get a verbally get
information from them when I went
through the all of the fine print
for the documents
it had buried in about the fourth page
was that you cannot trust any of the
representations made by our our your the
person who's selling you the tire
everything has to be written and and
this is the only thing that covers the
tires so they they didn't mention age at
all but they constantly said we wouldn't
sell you unsafe tires so we had slight
problem with that
any other questions representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you for coming
Representatives
um
I've been a manufacturer's rep for years
uh manufacturing many
representing many different types of
Manufacturers and one was a rubber
company and not tires I don't pretend to
be an expert on tires but um when uh
back then when we were evaluating uh the
Rubber products we would use the acronym
stamp which stood for size temperature
application media and pressure
those are all things besides age which
can affect the life of a rubber product
besides a tire and do you think those
should be considered
it would be nice if they considered all
of those things
and then they would have to apply that
the consideration of those things to to
the Tire in question on the trailer and
they might do that but we we didn't we
we think that when I when I brought the
tires to the dealer to explain and they
actually did pay for the tires that that
broke they
the tires there were some other issues
that they didn't want to take
responsibility for
um
but the very first thing they said I
said because I had then the I had to go
digging to get the result they initially
didn't give us the checklist result that
I had gotten previously
kind of Sir typical surreptitiously and
so I knew what the inspection was
supposed to do and when I actually saw
what was on the check tire list there
were some issues and there was no
mention of age and there were a lot of
things on it that weren't checked
so so that was an issue but the first
thing I said well this isn't checked
what what what how old should the tires
be what do you do there do you put the
date there and they say oh I'm sure they
they looked at it but it should be six
to eight years but the tires were eight
to nine you know eight to nine years so
there's an issue with dealers but that
has nothing to do with the bill I think
that it's a good thing to get more
disclosure for people especially for
used trailers because new trailers come
with new tires they come with all of
that so This only affects so for the big
deal is it's not a lot of trailers and
it's only people that are licensed
dealers so it doesn't affect individuals
that are selling Tire to selling
trailers so
I I would just add I think this is would
be a good start to for consumer
protection for road safety protection
for
Highway accident avoidance things like
that thank you any other questions
seeing then thank you again very much
the chairman yes could I just add the
shroutville Virginia is on the
Appalachian Trail and quite often it's
it's less than 500 people there but
quite often hikers come out of the
Appalachian Trail and visit in
Troutville so
there's your public service announcement
for the day
uh next up chair recognize is Nicholas
rudovic I think I said that right
um opposed to the bill representing the
RV industry Association looking for two
minutes
how was I with the name
you did very well thank you
uh chair Walsh Vice chair Gorski uh
thank you today uh thank you for this
opportunity to comment on hb132 my name
is Nick rudowicz I'm senior manager of
government Affairs for the RV industry
Association uh the RV industry
Association is the national trade
Association which represents the diverse
manufacturing businesses which
manufactures about 98 of all RVs which
are sold in the United States
I'm here today to both One support my
dealer partners and also to ask you to
not Advance HP 132 any further in the
legislative process
first there is no need for a utility
dealer or a deal or recreation vehicles
to provide a written document disclosing
the age and manufacture dates on tires
of a towable RV
in fact the code of federal regulations
specifically CFR title 49
574.5 requires the tire manufacturer to
stamp the manufacturer week and year
onto every Tire which is to be used on a
vehicle which meets nits or regulation
which towable recreation vehicles do
um I'll go into this a little bit more
on how this works on every Tire there's
a 12 to 13 digit code the last four
digits in this final group of the code
which is stamped on every tire is the
date code it's a simple system the first
two dates of the last four in this code
are the week of manufacture and the last
two dates of the year of manufacture so
if the tire was manufactured this week
it would say 0323
a simple internet search as well for
tire manufacture dates results in
countless links for tire manufacturers
tire retailers and vehicle enthusiasts
on how to identify a Tire's age and
manufacture date
second
the age and manufacture date of a tire
is not the correct determination of the
worthiness or safety status of a tire
age could have a factor but Tire use is
the single most important factor in the
tire's life for example
someone could have a well-kept
automobile or trailer which with proper
maintenance and storage could have tires
which are decades old and are acceptable
and safe to drive
on the other hand a vehicle which is
used quite often which is needs to be
which is used quite often and is not
well kept or stored may need to have the
tires replaced within months
Age Again is not the determining Factor
for the tires worthiness and safety
again Tire use is the critical piece
here
um furthermore to answer a few other
questions about blowouts and things like
that I think a few of the members of the
committee have brought this up but I'd
like to bring it up too and another
factor which is load
um load is critical too so without
knowing how the trailer was loaded the
tires could have been properly inflated
uh they could have had the proper PSI
they might have been safe but again
without knowing how the trailer was
loaded that's a critical Factor here as
well
so at that
um like I said before I just like to ask
the committee
um to please uh not Advance the bill any
further and I'm happy to take any
questions that any of the committee
members may have
thank you any questions from the
committee representative sellers
thank you Mr chair uh lucky me I bought
an RV in this last year and I've
researched the to the ends of the Earth
on tires and I bought a DPMS just to
make sure I know what the heat and
temperature was and rating
how would this
Bill hurt the dealer or would it hurt
the dealer at all just disclosing the
information or saying the tire is X
number years old
sure
um I could answer that question but I
believe uh Mr Bennett from the New
Hampshire automobile dealers will be
coming up and I think he might be able
to give you a better view of the dealer
point of view when it comes to this I
represent the manufacturing base and of
of the RV industry
follow-up thank you Mr chair
typically RVs are also used very seldom
I mean six eight 12 weeks a year and
then they're sitting around so there's
not that it is getting used like you're
thinking of a utility trailer possibly
so there's a combination that's going on
here how would you I don't know if
there's a way to determine that you know
because there is no inspection on RVs
do you have any ideas
sure so first and foremost we support
inspections on RVs when it comes down to
that so you know the safety of the
consumer is Paramount when it comes to
us in speaking to the other Point RV use
is going up more and more
um every single year as we've gone to a
remote work system throughout the
country more and more consumers are
actually using their RVs on a weekly
basis there are more consumers who like
to call themselves full-timers who will
go around the country and use the
vehicle you know quite often so there
there's a little bit of everything and
again that's why use is the critical
piece
any other questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um tires that are
eight to nine years old that show very
little tread wear obviously weren't used
regularly what is the ethical
responsibility of the dealership to
disclose the potential safety issues or
to take responsibility for those issues
sure again I represent the manufacturer
so I think the dealers would have to
answer that properly what I would say is
you know
I don't I've never heard of an interior
Tire inspection throughout my career in
the the automotive industry I think that
would be quite hard and quite labor
intensive for an inspector to do so the
only thing that the inspector has to go
by is going to be what they can see on
the outside from from my experience
and Dan Bennett is signed up to speak so
if you have any of those questions you
will have an opportunity any other
questions from the committee
and thank you very much
well speaking of that chair recognizes
Dan Bennett representative uh who is
opposed to the bill
um looking for three minutes
representing the New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh once again I'm Dan Bennett
from the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association you've had three bills and
you've heard from me twice so I have a
feeling we're going to get to be very
good friends
um at the break I did hand out a fact
sheet that we have that has all of my
contact info as
um promised earlier as well so
um with that I'll begin
um we uh we opposed this particular Bill
HP 132 I'm sorry for the unfortunate
experience that the representatives had
um but unfortunately and respectfully we
do in fact oppose it
um okay what I can do is recommend some
very reputable trailer dealers in the
state of New Hampshire that are both
nhada members and licensed by the New
Hampshire DMV so we can talk about that
offline
um date of birth does not indicate
condition
um
I'm in much better shape than some of my
friends my age and I am in much worse
shape than some of my friends of my age
it's about use it's wear and tear it's
ours it's a mechanical piece of
equipment so
um it's uh it's why we look at mileage
or on a vehicle or hours on an engine in
the case of snowmobiles or ATVs so it
really does come down to use blown tires
can happen for a multitude of reasons
with this bill
um like one that I mentioned earlier I I
don't know how this bill will be
enforced uh who's gonna but visit a
dealership and uh trailer dealership and
rip through every deal jacket to make
sure that this disclosure was and is or
given
so that's an issue if a consumer has
questions about equipment condition they
can always visit a reputable dealer or
technician and have equipment inspected
it's just like getting a second opinion
from your doctor so you can always uh
you can always get a second opinion
we do encourage periodic review of
inspection especially during a busy busy
trailer season and especially at the
start of season when you dust off that
trailer and right before you put it away
there's some preventative maintenance
things you can do dealers actually sell
bags you can see them on campers some
campers for their winter storage get
completely covered some folks put them
up off the ground and some folks put
protective bags really around the tire
to prevent dry rot and also an instance
that I mentioned earlier rodent
deterioration so those are things that
we all recommend when it comes to the
disclosure component
um
vehicle per the vehicle purchase process
is a very uh paperwork document
disclosure heavy transaction okay it's
not as heavy as buying a house right
where the stack of paper is this high
but there's a lot of papers in a in a
vehicle deal right so every time we add
another piece of paper it tends to
diminish
the importance of the others because
then that's why that's why it's called
passing papers right we start shuffling
and some of those documents tend to lose
their importance when we make it too
heavy so I I caution
um about the paperwork intensiveness and
the document disclosure component
um just as a point um we are sensitive
to you know other documents getting
watered down
um this isn't an inspection bill
we support inspections we always have we
supported trailer inspections even when
the legislature opposed or removed we
used to have trailer inspections and
then a few years ago the legislature
decided that anything under 10 000 GVW
for a trailer will no longer be
inspected
um we weren't supportive of that but
this is a date of birth disclosure bill
that's not a it's not a trailer
inspection Bill trailer Inspections just
to the point that was mentioned earlier
trailer inspections cover a lot of
things trailer inspections do cover
tires but they cover surface issues it's
not internal the tire isn't removed the
inside isn't scoured it's an it's an
external review for cuts tears scratches
wires showing and importantly tread
depth with it with a tread depth gauge
that's what's inspected at a on a tire
but in a trailer inspection there's a
whole host of other things the hitch the
wiring the turn signals the brake lights
the the hubs
um you know there's any Flex Points you
know being properly greased so there's a
whole host of things that do in fact go
into a trailer inspection it's not just
looking at tires
um so
um I just wanted to mention those few
things again I sympathize and I'm sorry
to hear about the sponsor's experience
I'm glad to hear that um that it was
that nothing bad happened that it was
safely resolved
um but unfortunately
um I don't think this particular piece
of legislation
um is the correct solution
um for a blowout on the highway that can
happen for a multitude of reasons so
um thank you and thanks for the time
um and I'll take any questions uh if
there are some I did uh I did hear a few
earlier that I may be able to address
thank you any questions from the
committee did you did you want your
answer representative sellers
yeah thank you chairman
um again the question is yeah it's
another piece of paper you're right and
you don't want to diminish the pieces of
the paper
but for a person
buying a trailer we know nothing and
they know nothing and and so at least
getting to the age of the tire
you've got date code giving him up front
at least they know how old it is if they
have an 86 or any e or Tire on there why
why do one just tell them
and and or recommended should be changed
just document it why what's what would
be the cost of the dealership just doing
that
okay so my response is so I guess we
could expand that too I don't know a
whole lot about my bicycle should we
have Tire disclosures for bicycles or
washing machines or any mechanical piece
of equipment
um but with this one so if they do
properly disclose it does it then make
the the dealer liable for something that
was totally out of their hands like hot
roads or over over usage or nails or bad
driving they scuff curbs so you
potentially open them for liability I
don't know see anything in this that
would release liability if the
disclosure is in fact issued so that's
one potential
um you may be requiring the technician
to make a use or a judgment call
did it pass on this snapshot in time or
are you asking me as a technician to
project whether this will last for 12
months or six months or 6 000 miles or
60 000 miles and then even with Tire
inspections as mentioned before Tire
inspections do not require
internal inspections removal
um you know Rim from Tire inside type
stuff so
um and if it did that would certainly be
a tremendous addition of time to an
inspection which would in fact raise
cost
so I think those are things that a
dealer would be sensitive to
so just a few thoughts
um if there's anything for the questions
thank you
CNN thank you very much thank you
uh next up Lieutenant O'Leary from New
Hampshire State Police uh not taking a
position on the bill looking for five
minutes
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee really appreciate a chair they
didn't have sides on it
um
so just as a another consideration
regarding enforcement with this uh
proposed language
the way that I see this under RSA
26653 or in the 266 section section
itself that section of law
um basically outlines the equipment
that's uh on vehicles so that's what our
state inspectors use when they conduct a
state inspection as a guideline for
whether or not a vehicle meets the
requirements so as on our end as fire
State Police is concerned if we're going
to enforce this if this this uh moves
forward
um I guess we would just need some
clarification as most of our
Motor Vehicle Dealer laws fall under the
261 section and that's where essentially
where we have a lot of our requirements
that the dealers have to you know give
certain things temporary plates odometer
statements and things like that so when
our crew goes in to do an audit at a
dealership if they're missing that
document then that's something that we
can address you know administratively
the way that this is written it my
perception is that this would fall on
safety mechanics to ensure that that's
um you know in check so we just want to
make sure we put it under the right
section of law if this does move forward
would be my request because the
enforcement part would be a second of
that you know is this going to be a
criminal law which we're going to
essentially arrest somebody for if they
do not comply with it or is this going
to be another document that we're just
checking for when we conduct an audience
sorry an audit to ensure that the dealer
is providing what's required
um and lastly if it does move forward
our other request would be that
um where it talks about the tire age and
date of manufacturer we just ask that
that would be in clear language because
sometimes what happens is exactly what
would happen here potentially you could
have a dealer that would write the
numbers or letters that correspond with
it leaving up to the buyer to determine
what any of that means so we would just
ask that the language be clear and what
that the age of the tire is that's all I
have sir
thank you questions from representative
sakes
thank you Mr chairman uh Lieutenant
O'Leary
is this the kind of
for lack of a better term regulation
that might be better
dealt with in rules rather than in
legislation
uh thank you for your question sir I'm
currently what we have in administrative
rules as members before me have spoken
to you know is that visual inspection of
tires I don't know that we could get any
you know um
any more strict on how tires are
inspected other than what we have right
now other than again like Mr Bennett
alluded to taking the tire right off the
rim but even then it's going to be
difficult to to determine so
administrative rule uh through that 261
law we could we could probably get it in
administrative rule that way but outside
of that with our current inspection
rules that it's not a I don't think a
good fit
yes sir thank you for your question for
the questions representative Sinclair
instead of a whole another sheet of
paper wouldn't it just to be as easy to
just have one little line that says age
of tires and
um that would give I mean I'm going to
look at a tire just to look at what it
looks like and if I guess if it's 10
years old then I can think about it but
at least it would give the consumer just
another little bit of information and
then if they want to freak out about the
age they can still freak out about it or
not it would be up to them but just just
a little line
thank you representative I I don't want
to speak on behalf of the the bill
sponsors but I assume based on what I've
seen um you know with car sales as the
paperwork is required now the reason why
the odometer statement is is a separate
statement it is to you know put more
emphasis on that so adding a adding a
line somewhere
um I'm thinking that their thought is it
would be Lost in Translation and they're
looking for to put emphasis on this this
item all right thank you thank you so
for the questions
I'm just seeing that I just have one
just just to to clarify so intercurrent
inspection laws the date that's stamped
on there the week in the year is not by
itself enough to fail a tire it's all
based on physical
appearance that's correct sir thank you
any other questions thanks again thank
you
that is the last person I have signed up
to speak so I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 132. uh
next up
what is our next bill
153 give us a couple of minutes to reset
please
okay being 3 15 and I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 153
relative to roadway pedestrian control
signals uh chair recognizes
representative Faulkner the prime
sponsor
um floor is yours welcome thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee uh
this is a short and simple Bill to fix
what I see as problems with RSA 26511
which controls pedestrian signals that
signalize intersections
first I think it might help to explain
my interest in the subject I'm a
semi-retired lawyer now but I had a
30-year career in transportation
planning
projects I worked on involved traffic
circulation pedestrian
parking and towns from Massachusetts to
Hartford San Antonio New Orleans
Southern California
that was part of the team that
documented and provided for the tens of
thousands of pedestrian movements that
crossed the path of the of Boston's big
dig construction project back in the 90s
these projects typically involve
balancing the needs of buses and other
Transit automobile drivers trucks and
pedestrians parking and of course the
businesses that depend on all this
so as I'm used to read recently that
California had repealed its anti-j
walking laws
I was stopped by a police officer in
California once for jaywalking so I
certainly got to see that firsthand
I was let off with a warning when I
explained that we're from New England
and we can cross the street there
legally
but in California Jay we're locking laws
were once part of a a strong automobile
culture
uh where streets reserved for cars and
not for people
but now you can cross the street in
California as long as you don't
interfere with traffic
that prompted me to look at rjwalking
and other anti-pedestrian laws and while
we're not as Andy pedestrians California
once was we do have numerous
restrictions on how when and and where
people can use the street
these restrictions most are punishable
less violations are in various places in
RSA 265. this bill only addresses one
situation Crossing at an intersection
where there are pedestrian walk and
don't walk signals
it's controlled by RSA 260 511.
there are two problems with the statute
as it's now written
first it refers to signals with the
words walk and don't walk for
pedestrians
these particular signals are Obsolete
and have been for 20 years
the manual of uniform traffic control
devices has required the white
walking figure and the orange upraised
hand
for new installations of pedestrian
signals since the 2003 Edition
more importantly RSA 26511 has written
prohibits certain crossings that are
legal at every other intersection in the
state that is crossing the street within
the crosswalk parallel with the vehicle
movements uh that are that are parallel
to the direction you're Crossing Street
in
um the rules we learned as kids are
pretty simple at crosswalks with no
traffic signals pedestrians have the
right of way
you look listen look both ways
and then
only then we across
in the crosswalk and under those
circumstances pedestrians have the right
away
I'm happy that most drivers in the state
and certainly near where I live most
drivers honor this rule
now it signalized intersections
pedestrians crossing the street
must yield to through vehicles that have
the green signal while turning Vehicles
yield to pedestrians that are in the
crosswalk this works just fine at
hundreds hundreds of intersections
across the state
however under the current pedestrian
signal statute there's another rule one
that can contradict the normal rule
that his pedestrians must wait for and
obey the PED signal even if the cross
even if they're crossing the street is
otherwise legal and safe
it's a particular problem with
pedestrian activated signals these are
the crossing signals that constantly
display don't walk until pedestrian
pushes a button they would then activate
The Pedestrian signal on the next cycle
pedestrian has to wait up to two minutes
for the cycle to come around to the to
uh The Pedestrian signal and if it's an
exclusive pedestrian phase that causes
all the other traffic in both directions
to have to wait
for at least 20 seconds often a lot more
the rule that prohibits people from
Crossing when they orange hand is raised
or right now it just says don't walk
it's rarely enforced and frequently
ignored and in fact somebody crossing
the street in a safe manner legal at all
other intersections
um isn't doing an unsafe act by crossing
the street but you know the unsafe act
occurs only if they fail the yield
uh do other traffic or traffic fields to
yield to The Pedestrian
so that the
uh the provision that
it's still prohibited if if The
Pedestrian interferes with traffic uh
will still work
uh
right now with the obsolete language
it's not clear that this
current statute applies anywhere because
whereas there may be some older signal
systems that still use the the don't
walk words in most places they don't but
rather than trying to repeal the section
I've suggested two updates
one is to update the uh the first part
that says refers to the don't walk and
don't and walk signals to include
equivalent symbols that are provided for
under the manual
of uniform traffic control devices
right now that's the upraised hand and
the walking figure
and the second fix is it says the
pedestrians are only in violation if
they interfere with traffic that has the
right of way
if this bill does not
compromise safety it doesn't change
anything that's out there on the street
now
pedestrian signals will continue to
operate the way they they do now anyone
who wants to or needs to use the
have the Assurance of a walk signal can
still push the button or wait until the
signal changes
now this builds a small change designed
to chip away at the notion that cars are
King
and pedestrians don't belong in our
cities and towns
that's all I have to say and I'd be glad
to take questions
thank you representative for any
questions from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I read this three times and I
really aside from the fact that maybe
this is a bookkeeping thing is there any
other purpose to this besides just
changing the language so that it
reflects current right technology
they're two parts the first part just
includes the new signals as as provided
in the mutcd
the second part
changes right now it says that if you
step off the curb when the you know when
the don't walk signal is displayed
you're in violation and subject to a
ticket
the change is that you can cross
if it's safe to do so if you can do so
without interfering with traffic
and you don't get a ticket unless you in
fact walk in front of
uh cars that have the green signal
so it it doesn't it doesn't penalize the
crossing of the street which is not
necessarily an unsafe to act it only
penalizes
The Pedestrian if they if they do
something that in fact is unsafe
quick follow-up yeah follow-up thank you
are these not uh where these occur are
these not uh mostly covered by city
ordinance
well right now well it like the cities
can certainly have an ordinance but if
it doesn't conform to the statute it has
to be it has to be a clear signage to
indicate
that
a different set of rules applies
so uh
you know if if somebody wants to
absolutely prohibit any pedestrian
movements
an example on the
right now you can turn right on red
after coming to a stop in your vehicle
the city can decide that that's not a
safe movement in this particular
location but if they want to prohibit
right turns on red they have to make the
sign is particularly clear that that
different set of rules applies at that
intersection
so the same would apply here if they
they really want to keep people from
Crossing
according to the
the other rules the rules that apply
other than that
these pet signal intersections they may
have to make that clear to the you know
the people walking on the street
thank you
representative O'Hara thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um do you
I could just see this going as could in
Laconia we have six Lane intersections
it could you could not be interfering
for the first three lanes and then
you're stuck on an island and then what
happens to The Pedestrian do they stand
there in the island do they have a clear
way to go the next three lanes or I just
I I know it'll work well in Concord for
like these small back roads but in
Laconia it would be bad
was there a question
um
so what it you know depends on how this
intersection is designed
so the signal timing
is supposed to be such that a pedestrian
can cross the street
on the phase where that is a safe move
so and that depends upon
the general rule is you take the the
width that they have to cross divided by
three and a half feet per second and
seven seconds per at open time and then
you know so a 50-foot Street you know
you want to have a 30 second
uh
well less than 30 seconds of time for
pedestrians to cross so
if there's not enough time for them to
cross then the intersections in the
phasing is not designed correctly
a follow-up
question yeah so where I was trying to
get with it is we're trying to say that
as long as they're not interfering with
traffic they can walk on the do not walk
correct that's correct okay and then if
in Laconia there's a six-lane
intersection they may not be interfere
they may think they'd not be going to be
interfere because they can't see you
know 35 seconds out but car comes down
the corner then they're doing pretty
much traffic who are we gonna like
the car comes around the corner they
have to yield to The Pedestrian so
turning traffic always has to yield to
pedestrians
foreign
thank you Mr chairman I'm looking in
here and I don't see uh
clearly saying that you can go ahead and
cross even though it says don't walk
assuming that the traffic it doesn't say
that that well it talks about where
uh you've already started
but this changes that no pedestrians
shall cross the road away in the
direction of such signals when a don't
walk or equivalent signal is displayed
if such Crossing interferes with
vehicular traffic
so it says not to cross when the note
walk is displayed
uh
if if in you know under the conditions
that that interferes so if there's no
traffic
and you cross when this says don't walk
there's no traffic in either direction
there's no violation
under the proposed
rule
any further questions
representative Sinclair
would you consider a friendly amendment
to this that if somebody
pushes the walk thing and then walks
across doesn't wait for it to come on
and holds up traffic that that would be
a violation of some sort right well you
know that happens all the time now and
it creates a lot of resentment
and this hopefully would reduce that if
you feel confident that you can you know
when to cross the street safely
then you don't push the button and right
now you go out and look at any other in
sections in the area here and you'll see
people doing that right now this this
law has violated dozens of times a day
um because exactly that no nobody wants
to be the bad guy that you know stops
traffic when you when it's not necessary
but you know if you're
unsure about walking or unsure about
your eyesight or whatever and you need
that then you need to have those buttons
uh for that circumstance but you know
the extent that this helps reduce the
conflict between cars and
not just the physical conflict but also
this exactly what you're talking about
the resentment that builds up when
pedestrians
hold up traffic
you know if there's less resentment then
there's less aggressive driving and
it may end up being a safer situation
overall
and yet representative Style
Mr chairman
um as I look at Roman numeral two you
read the first part that says that a
pedestrian even though it says don't
walk if there is no traffic they can go
forward and move across the street but
the second part says however any
pedestrian who has partially completed
her or his Crossing on the walk signal
shall proceed to a sidewalk or safety
island is that contradictory or
redundant or unnecessary no that that
basically says that if you are
in the in the crossing and the light
turns you know hand comes up
right then you were instructed to
continue
that's the current that's the current
law so that you
you continue to the nearest point of
safety and then you know you still have
the right of way yeah follow-up
yeah I'll give you follow up but yeah so
my question is is that still necessary
if I mean because you know certainly I
have entered into a crossrock and then
the thing starts blinking when I'm in
I'm in the middle of the street and then
I I go but if we get rid of the idea
that if there's no traffic coming that
you have to wait for the the little man
to come on
um then it's unlikely that you'll be in
the middle some people will still use
The Pedestrian signals and there's some
places where the pedestrian signal comes
on that in every cycle
you know parallels with the movement of
traffic so there are situations where
somebody has started out
and
uh
you know they're still in the middle of
the crosswalk
you know somebody walks slowly for
example I mean a 3.5 feet per second is
pretty pretty brisk
If somebody walks slowly maybe halfway
across the in the intersection when the
green light comes on for the for the
traffic now they have to continue to
they they get to continue to the curb
thank you continue to have the right of
way that's all that that phrase means
and that's in the current statute as
well okay thank you
any further questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you
uh next she recognizes representative
Rhodes uh in support of the bill looking
for two to three minutes
oh this is 260. sorry it's in the wrong
pile I apologize
uh so chair recognizes William Lambert
from New Hampshire Department of
Transportation
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh welcome back
um for those that don't know me there's
a lot of new faces here my name is Bill
Lambert I'm the state traffic engineer
for the New Hampshire D.O.T and before I
forget the answer to representative
staub's question is that that the
sentence that you're referring to is in
the paragraph for a don't walk display
so it essentially says if you are in the
crosswalk during walk display and then
it turns to don't walk they don't want
you to turn around and go backwards they
keep going to where you your destination
was because the signal is a time so that
you can get to The Far Side pedestrian
signals are very complicated
um there's probably a lot of job
security for me because people don't
understand how they're supposed to work
and they tend to be modified for the
record I just returned from Washington
DC I spent three days there last week
with 353 like-minded folks talking about
exactly what's in the mutcd so if you
can imagine what kind of experience that
is that's what I'm coming from today so
welcome home thank you very much so the
dot is not opposed to this bill I think
the language is somewhat clunky and I
think some of the questions that I heard
earlier kind of indicate that and and I
also wanted to talk about and attach it
to the handout or the written comments
that I have is
discuss the uniform vehicle code so the
uniform vehicle code
is a um is a document that's created by
a collective of 50 states it hasn't been
updated since the year 2000 but within
the uniform vehicle code in the uniform
vehicle code includes model laws and
ordinances for all things vehicles and
going to representative Sinclair's
question about the federal issue with
tires those types of things are in the
uniform vehicle code so that when States
adopt rules of the road that they're
consistent that people know what they're
gonna what they are from state to state
but the uniform vehicle code has
language that if you look on the page
129 of the attachment under their
chapter 11-203 pedestrian control
signals is almost verbatim so it's in
our in our statutes and there's a reason
for that because the uniform vehicle
code is created so that states can adopt
consistent language so if I look at the
language that's in that 11 203
pedestrian control signals
just to clear up within our current uh
statute
rather than or the equivalent visual or
audible signals in reference to the
mutcd it simply says
The Walker don't walk or symbols of a
walking person or up raised Palm are in
place so that that would be consistent
with the uniform vehicle code and I
think it's cleaner language
I look at paragraph two when it's it's
proposed in the cross out steadier or
flashing in one of the things that I
look at on this and again pedestrian
signals are kind of evolving over time
right now we don't flash the walk symbol
but the mutcd in the current
infrastructure bill that just passed
last year
um includes a requirement that Federal
Highway will adopt in the next edition
of the mutcd by May of this year so
there may be changes to what's in the
current bill and one of the changes
they've talked about is having instead
of the Walk The don't walk with the
countdown symbol if you've seen that on
any of the newer signals you would have
the walk
um flashing so it would come up at the
beginning of the Walk face pedestrian
phase would walk steady and then when it
got to a point where there was only
enough time to cross the length of the
road it would start flashing don't it
would stop flashing walk with the
countdown number to let people know how
much time there was
um so I I would I would tend to leave
this the flashing or steady or flashing
in the lane in the build just because I
think it it may change in the near
future and it doesn't hurt the way it is
and then in the last paragraph the don't
walk paragraph uh the when they don't
walk or equivalent signal is displayed I
think is redundant to the clarification
that was in the first paragraph it
doesn't necessarily add and may even add
some confusion and then leave it just as
it it's shown in my writ uh written
comments on the second page I had what
it would be in a clean clean document
in the last paragraph
and um
again we're not going to comment on on
the merits of the bill I'd be happy to
answer any questions on it
um but I'm just looking at cleaning it
up to be more consistent with the
uniform vehicle code
and with that I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you sir any questions
from the committee
representative Hill thank you and thank
you Mr Lambert for coming in and
speaking with us
um would you be willing to help with a
an amendment to clean up the language
that we
that you just discussed
absolutely thank you for the question
I'd be I'd be happy to thank you
you beat me to it representative Hill
thank you
representative C
thank you Mr chairman
um just trying to figure this out and
I'm just wondering uh on the bill itself
on line 11. it looks to me like uh we
should strike out where it says on the
walk signal so it just says if any
pedestrian has partially completed his
or her Crossing shall proceed to the
sidewalk or safety aisle
because we're talking about the
possibility of people uh starting
without waiting for the walk
indication correct and thank you for the
question so again this is another
paragraph that's titled don't walk so it
has to do with the the uh the ref the
references that it's what to do on the
don't walk symbol so that last sentence
indicates that if you have partially
completed the Crossing
um you shall proceed to to a sidewalk a
safety Island on the walk I think is
something that was clarified in this
state maybe different than the uniform
vehicle code I don't know if it adds or
detracts from it I think it's just a
clarifying statement but it's
essentially if you're if you're in a
crosswalk when it starts to flash don't
walk
um you're supposed to keep walking and
to get to the either the other side or
to a safety Island and like um
representative the sponsor said
um traffic signals a time so that the uh
it's I think it's three feet per second
because of the Aging population but uh
their their time to allow a pedestrian
to go from one side to the far side it
used to be to the middle of the lane on
the farthest Lane but now it's curb to
curb so that we make sure that somebody
has enough time to get all the way
across
any other questions
um I agree well with uh representative
Hill I was going to ask the same
question I think the original language
and the current law which is what's in
regular type is confusing to begin with
uh the extra language doesn't help so
I'm anxious myself to see if you can
work on something that helps it just a
little easier for everybody to read I
think we'll have a better look at it
then because I don't see anybody with
any opposition per se to what's being
attempted uh I have nobody else signed
up to speak so thank you very much I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 153 and just a minute or so
and we'll get into house bill 260.
okay being 341 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 260 FN
prohibiting the operation of Motor
Vehicles by drivers with animals on
their laps
um chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Rhodes
floor is yours
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
chairman Walsh Vice chairman Gorski
members of the committee for the record
my name is Jennifer Rhodes I am the
state representative for Cheshire County
District 17 which is Winchester Richmond
Swansea Troy and Fitzwilliam
I'm here this afternoon to introduce you
to House Bill 260 FN
which as you just heard is prohibiting
pets from or animals being on a driver's
lap while they're operating a vehicle
uh the reason this bill came about was
over the summer uh the little girl that
lives across the street for me or used
to she was there visiting her
grandmother
little girl wasn't doing anything wrong
she was actually on the sidewalk where
she was supposed to be and before she
crossed the street there was a car
coming so she was actually going up the
sidewalk
you know
she was going up the sidewalk instead of
just crossing I guess give herself
something to do for those couple seconds
till the car passed
and the car that was driving down the
street
had two dogs
on his arm and he was steering with the
left arm with the two dogs that were
resting on this arm and at the same time
he was petting these dogs unfortunately
the little girl was on a little one of
those little Razor scooters and she hit
a bump and she fell off of her scooter
onto the street
and the car being more distracted with
petting his dogs instead of actually
able to steer to avoid this almost hit
the little girl the only reason he
didn't was because the grandmother
happened to be there and she was able to
grab her and pull her off the street
so I remember thinking back when I was
you know a teenager and I would see
embarrassingly enough my grandfather
driving down the road with his dog on
his arm and I used to say are you crazy
that's like the stupidest thing I've
ever seen
and then I kind of forgot about it and
then when this happened I was like
that's it this is absolutely ridiculous
and then I started looking into it
and there was nothing that said that you
weren't allowed to do this and I took it
upon myself to call a couple
representatives to see if they'd be
interested in co-sponsoring a bill or
what they thought and surprisingly a lot
of people said you don't need to write
that bill it's already illegal
and it is not already illegal
when I wrote this piece of legislation I
never in my wildest dreams thought that
this would become one of the more
controversial controversial bills of the
session but by God here we are
so
um
the newspaper did an article and I
received my fair share of hate grams
that came after the article was written
and I also received my share of thank
God it's about time
one of the emails I received was from a
lady that had her brother-in-law that
was killed
by a driver that had his pet on his lap
and came around the bends kind of a
similar situation and and hit him and
you know he and his wife were taking a
walk and he was struck by him and he
died
another lady wrote me a not so kind
email telling me how horribly rude I was
because she loves her dogs and how dare
I say that she can't drive around the
road with him on her lap
well she went on to say how that if she
was taking her dog unfortunately to be
put down and that I had better believe
that she would be holding her dog for
his last breaths on the way to the vet
I've owned three Saint Bernards in my
lifetime
sadly all three of my dogs have had to
been put down
the one was one year old he was 168
pounds so according to her logic there
was absolutely no reason that I couldn't
drive down the road consoling my dog
because I loved him just as much as she
loves her dog
but apparently the only reason anybody
has is because they love their dog
I remember once upon a time when people
would drive down the road with their
children on their laps I was one of
those people my mother used to hold me
on her lap
we don't do that anymore that is illegal
it took something right a lot of bad
things happen
so while I was doing the research on
this bill
I know this is going to be a question so
I would like to answer it currently
Hawaii is the one and only state that
has a law that specifically prohibits
animals from being on a person's lap
only Hawaii however
many many states are far more
restrictive Massachusetts says that
a dog has to be
restrained some way so if the person you
know if the if the passenger is driving
down the road it's okay for the
passenger to be holding the dog but that
dog or cat lizard whatever it may be is
not allowed to basically cross that line
it has been or somebody's control
um
hold on a second please
so New Jersey
Rhode Island Arizona Connecticut Hawaii
as I mentioned Iowa Maine Massachusetts
South Carolina Washington DC all have
some kind of destructive driver's laws
that say most of them say that the dog
has to actually be
or cat says that the animal has to be
restrained a lot of the laws say that
they actually have to be in a carrier or
some kind of a seat belt
so I was not trying to be you know that
prohibitive and say that you actually
have to restrain your dog or your cat
um but I thought this was at least
something
so the the statistics
show that a dog that weighs 30 pounds if
they were to be in a car crash would be
exert roughly 300 pounds of pressure
a dog that weighs 80 pounds
says that it would be a dog that weighs
80 pounds would exert approximately 2400
pounds of force
so needless to say if you're actually
driving with this pet on your lap and
the airbag deploys
the dog the cat is going to get killed
it's that simple it's going to get
killed
however just because they're on the
passenger seat there even if the airbag
deploys which it may not because it
might not weigh enough to make it if
it's on your lap as you're the driver
that is absolutely going to happen
the problem that we have is there aren't
any real statistics that show how many
people or what the danger is
and the other states that have been
trying to pass laws where I actually
found either the representatives or the
senators all said the same thing that I
have said that the pushback that they've
got was that there aren't any real
statistics that show that
so according to AAA
um
they are saying that the the potential
dangers are enough that legislators
should be making some kind of decision
on whether or not they're going to do
this it goes on to talk about
um
different studies that have been done
over the years and it says
um
hold on a second here oh it talks about
the fact that an animal is not allowed
or doesn't have the ability to actually
brace themselves if and when there was
going to be any kind of an accident
so with all that you know kind of to the
to the point
um being on
criminal justice I know how
some of the people in our committee can
just take a bill right down to the bone
and
you know find anything so the reason
that I had to put you know anywhere in a
person is because I could think of a
couple Representatives that would say
well it's not on my lap he's on my arm
okay well that's okay
um or they would say well it's not on my
lap who's up on the dashboard so that is
the reason that I you know kind of had
to be
you know a little bit more aggressive
was because I was trying to think of
some of the pushback that we've had from
some of the other bills that I've heard
over the time
so that is
my legislation thank you
thank you representative any questions
from the committee
you do okay representative Gorski thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question you have here the violation
for this is a hundred dollars yes
what happens after the second time is it
still a hundred dollars is it a hundred
dollars every time
thank you for the question
I did not come up with the penalty in
what it should be I sent the the
potential legislation over with a list
of with a list of questions that I had
and whether or not you know how the
fines should be and this is what that
this is what they had sent me back
so on unfortunately I don't really have
you know an answer that if it would be
you know a stricter penalty the second
and or third time
any other questions from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair representative um
what age group demographics does this
really hit
I mean has it been any study to say that
people over 50 have dogs on their laps
or people under 50.
thank you for your question
it has been found that since the
pandemic that pet ownership has reached
an all-time high of over 70 percent of
outs of households actually owning
some form of a pet I think that you
probably or everybody in this room has
probably seen that going simply to the
grocery store you're going to see a
handful of people that now walk around
with some kind of a pet
so unfortunately I don't have an answer
of the age group of people that actually
drive with a pet on their lap but I
assure you ever since I actually had the
courage to put this in writing
I've lost count at how many people drive
down the road sadly not with just one
but multiple pets on their arm and it's
all ranges
first drivers up until
senior citizens and and much much older
any further questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um did you mention what the danger is to
the driver in an accident with a that's
that has a pet on their lap what the
force would be
you know driving the the pet into their
body or you know the impact Force
thank you for your question
I was not
to answer your specific question none of
that came up in any of the research that
I did the only thing that came up was
the danger to the pet itself which is
um basically a lot most of the
information I found was basically with
AAA and the statistics that I read you
are all from trip away and it just gives
different examples of pets in their
different size and continues to talk
about the fact that you know if they go
they go through the windshield and the
other dangers that happen is if there is
a collision when I spoke with some EMT
First Responders that a lot of times
whenever they get to the scene
unfortunately the dog is running down
the road because whenever they get hurt
they run and or if the dog is hurt or
the or their owner is hurt they won't
allow the First Responders to actually
get to the person to do whatever may be
done because they're protecting them so
I don't know what actually happens to
the driver other than you know the real
dangers of any other wreck that they
might be in
for the questions
um I heard you already had one
representative Jones
and uh
microphone thank you representative for
bringing this forward in uh I I just
want to ask uh section 265 that you're
amending is that a distracted driving
section and I should have looked that up
myself I didn't so I'm asking you so
thank you for the question when I
submitted this legislation I did say
that I was you know basically looking to
add this to the distracted driving laws
which is what all the other states that
I mentioned to you
all say none of them necessarily say you
can't have the pet but they just have
that if you get that they can pull you
over for that
um so the way this was written is it was
basically just a new section but my
understanding is yes it's going to be
with the distracted driving laws which
are mostly all cell phone and if I could
just add to that one of the things that
I've gotten from several officers that
have called me which have been a lot I
reached out to the police Chiefs in my
town I've reached out to friends that I
have that are officers every single
person was in support of it and
unfortunately they're all working so
they're not here but the first thing
that a lot of people said to me was why
aren't you adding makeup okay I mean one
thing at a time I mean I think it's
foolish to drive down the road putting
makeup on as well
um but again a lot of people think that
that's already illegal but apparently if
it's not in writing it it doesn't count
thank you
represent representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
who's going to determine that it's if
the animals on are in the person's hands
or arms a lap that it's impeding his or
her access
I mean
it could be different for every every
person well thank you for your question
which is exactly why it says that
basically the pet cannot be
in the driver's area for for the exact
reasons that you just said right if a
person's driving down the road and the
dog is on their arm well the dog's not
on my lap so that's okay
right so the end of the day the pet
being
with the driver
is clearly a distraction and that is
what we're trying to prevent we're
trying to
help the dog and the safety of the dog
which is clearly not in its and it's
safe being you know transported in its
safest manner and it certainly is a
distraction to be driving down the road
and have something you know that's
moving sitting on your lap
of Hill thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representatives for coming and
visiting us
is there any
thoughts or exclusions for service
animals
thank you for your question
representative
the service animal can certainly be in
your vehicle
right the service animal can be on
according to this legislation the
service animal can be sitting on the
passenger on the passenger seat
I
I don't think that it makes any more
sense to have the the service animal be
on your lap
than it does to have it sitting right
next to you
I I would have to say no
although I find it hard to believe that
a real service animal would be sitting
on the lap
you used to be sitting right next to
them but any other questions from the
committee
CNN thank you very much thank you
uh next up chair recognizes Eli Rivera
in support of the bill looking for two
minutes uh representing himself are you
also a sheriff
greetings
good afternoon Mr representative Welch
and the members of the committee my name
is Ila Rivera and I'm the sheriff in
Cheshire county and I've been to share
for 11 years
I support this bill for a number of
reasons and and I'm going to bring up we
currently have a statue on 265.95 that
talks about the obstruction to Driver's
view or writing mechanism and it
actually has to deal with passengers so
if you try to squeeze in four passengers
in a in a three passenger seat like
before you have the bench seats and you
can try to squeeze as many people as you
could in the front seat and you drive
right against the the driver door and
you're doing one of these numbers you
know that was kind of what that bill
came into
um or you know you just have
um people that are leaning against the
driver as they're driving or so kind of
obstructing how the driver can reach
either the emergency brakes or even the
gears or all the steering wheel itself
um and it also talks about obstructing
The View you know um if you have
stickers or even tinted windows you know
obstruct your way to look out the side
mirrors inside
um Windows you know it kind of there's a
legislation that talks about and and
deals with those consequences
um pets have sometimes in our mind I've
seen dogs running back and forth between
the front seat the back seat looking out
one window looking out the other window
and and I seen
um drivers of pets that are
well they're holding with their left
hand and they're trying to look over the
over the dog as they're driving down the
road so it does cause a hazard and then
if we are saying that you cannot have
um any something anything that strucks
you view if you have
a dog of whatever size you know it is
obstructing your view because when you
look it might be reflecting your side of
your mirror it can be struck and as you
look out because the dog is right there
in your view and it just kind of creates
that distraction
um
over the years I have stopped people
because I felt that that watching a dog
you know was just kind of in a position
back in the days when I was in the
patrol I pulled people over because I
felt that you know
I understand you love your dog but you
know how can you even drive with that
dog when you can't even see out the
front window or out to the side you know
you might want to consider
um putting him somewhere else and and
consider whether that was considered
negligent drive you know how can you
drive when you you're obstructing
yourself from what's in front of you or
into the side of you
um whether it's a Chihuahua whether it's
a lab I've seen it every size dogs on
people's lives you know if you start
talking about something that's more than
a you know 30 pound dog or whatever you
know then that that really gets in the
way and when the representative um asks
about the um the airbag you know the
airbag is meant to protect the driver or
the passenger in the car if you have a
dog or something in between the airbag
and the person with the air bag deploys
now you're obstructing the real purpose
of that airbag because you have put
place in obstruction in between the
passage the the driver of the passenger
whoever that is and the air back and
that's going to most likely cause more
harm or reduce the capabilities of the
airbag as it deploys because now it's
facing a destruction instead of being
hit by the airbag you can emit my airbag
that's pushing your dog into your face
or whatever that is you know so there's
some more serious consequences when you
have a dog in your lap and and hopefully
nothing ever happens but that airbag
doesn't pause you're going to be hit
with a lot more weight behind it because
now you have something something
obstructing it
um again we have
um legislation that does deal with the
obstruction of you and and obstructing
the driver's mechanism already in place
adding that in addition to passengers or
or any other
item that you put on on your window that
dogs can also cause that obstruction and
and
a view and and the mechanism of the car
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
seeing then thank you again
uh next up
Lieutenant O'Leary
from New Hampshire State Police Troop G
uh no not taking a position on the bill
at this time
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um representative Rhodes to the
phenomenal job setting this the uh this
whole thing up because
although we are not taking a position on
this I think one of the things to
um to understand and the point that she
brought up being that our hands are
somewhat tied when it comes to
distracted driving and I think just by
the nature of the term distracted
driving the general public thinks that
you know we have an authority to act on
people who are distracted and and it's
uh it's complicated it's a complicated
matter there are only a couple of laws
that specifically speak to distracted
driving one being when you're using a
cell phone and one being when you're
texting those two specifically speak to
to distracted driving now outside of
that we have negligent driving and
negligent driving is for someone who
drives a vehicle that in a manner in
which could cause uh harm to a person or
property the difficult part in that law
is that deciphering or articulating that
event of is potentially could cause an
issue so for example if I have somebody
who is eating an ice cream and Crosses
is over the yellow line and strike
somebody I can certainly articulate that
they're driving negligently however if I
have someone eating an ice cream you
know and only not paying attention only
having one hand on the wheel that's not
something I could stop them for as being
distracted so in the case of an animal
or anything that's going to be a
distraction in this in this case being
an animal
we don't have a distracted driving law
and and I think representative Rhodes
did a great job of trying to to bring
that to your attention because we again
that's something that most people think
that we have and we don't have
that's what I wanted to talk about
all right thank you very much questions
from the committee representative St
Claire
I like to keep you busy I this is a
question and we spoke earlier about this
in your experience all the years on the
force would you give up
a shout out at maybe the percentage of
people you think actually drive around
with
animals on their laps just just a guess
so thank you for your question that's a
difficult question I have seen it and I
have seen people that have you know
driven over the yellow line and such so
those are you know circumstances which
I'm acting on that secondary violation I
you know I see the distraction not
anything I can act on but I do see him
cross the yellow line it is something
that I have seen throughout my 20 years
that being said I do know that
distracted driving is one of the number
one issues that we have in our state and
across the country so
um you know the difficult part is we
don't capture information related to
what the distraction is so if somebody's
involved in a crash we show up we
investigate we say yep it's uh you know
contributing factors distracted driving
that could be anything anything that's a
distraction
you're welcome thank you for your
question what are the questions
representative Coker uh thank you Mr
chairman Lieutenant so a quick question
I have so we the this you said
distracted driving is kind of a
secondary if I guess um offense you
so the two laws that we have uh are for
cell phone uses essentially whether
you're hands-free or text messaging the
negligent driving is is essentially the
the captures anything that is as a
result of distracted driving okay so do
you think like maybe instead of um you
know there's I feel like there might be
like a lot of one-off situations where
you're kind of adding you know like we
had a bill for a dog in the lab stuff
like that you think this might be an
opportunity to possibly roll in just a
blanket distracted driving type of
legislation I mean with that I guess
would would that help with enforcement
or at least being able for you guys
being able to pull people over for these
issues and have you know basically
having a legislative backing for it yeah
thank you for your question right so
that I I agree if we could find
something that would you know basically
capture all of those instances that
would be awesome
um however that obviously is challenging
to be able to articulate what exactly is
going to be straight distracting and not
so if if the committee believes that
we're able to capture that that would be
great if we can capture this along with
other distracted driving in some sort of
legislation
thank you for question
committees representative sellers thank
you Mr chair so if we go that way uh
I could be drinking a coffee in an
office officer could see me and said
you're distracted is that true
if that's again where that's kind of a
hypothetical proposal to legislation and
I think that that's that's why we've
gone with the negligent driving charge
for so long because you could be
drinking a coffee and uh and and
nothing's happening but you could be
reaching for that coffee and it spills
in your lap and you cross the yellow
line and hit somebody and now it's
become negligent so it's that fine line
between being distracted and what it you
know what contributes to something
that's negligent
foreign any other questions
I just have one so in summary obvious
the negligences and after the fact
charge yes sir and and you could
uh probably charge somebody with
negligence if you found the dog in
between the steering wheel and the human
being and so so that's pretty simple my
question is
do you think that the language that the
way it's currently written would be
enforceable for the for preventing it
from from the distraction part of it
from what I've read I mean on its face
value it's simply if the dogs in the lap
it's a violation and I think that if the
committee finds that that's a you know a
level distraction I think that that's uh
that's pretty easy to be able to enforce
on our end okay all right thank you
um seeing no other questions thank you
very much thank you sir uh no other pink
cards I'm going to close the public
hearing on
House Bill 260 FN
okay so that's the end of our business
today
I will be scheduling our early bills for
next Tuesday
um we've got seven of them actually the
way we went today maybe that's all we're
going to do next week is seven any other
questions for me before we finish our
business for the day what time Tuesday
excuse me what time Tuesday
um I typically I like to start early
nine o'clock usually
it won't be any earlier than that
um but it depends on what I'll have to
look at the bills if I think they're
easy like I did today or how'd that work
um I move it to ten but I think I think
safe and safe enough uh
we'll probably be starting at nine I'll
speak with the ranking member also about
any of the bills that we've heard today
whether or not we want to exec them next
week
um but the ones we heard today are not
early so those aren't under a deadline
yet so the next week's public herd bills
are go ahead
the three bills before us that are that
we didn't act on today will they be
agendaized for next Tuesday excuse me
excuse me guys
I didn't hear you excuse me
gentlemen I can't hear please thank you
no not yet I'm answering some so one
more time no I'm just asking that
there's three bills that were before us
today that we are they going to be
agendized for next Tuesday those bills I
didn't even notice that we had three
extra I just worked off the ones that I
scheduled last week okay yeah I don't
know why they're there okay you just put
extra ones typically we might typically
we get a copy of all of them from from
committee Services
um but I though things may be changing
there because I know things are trying
to go paperless so I'll confirm whether
or not we're going to get a copy
typically most of the representatives
keep an index file and keep them all
with all your notes um I still like
doing it that way myself but I'll follow
up and uh if you would like copies you
can certainly request them from Lindsay
uh yourself but
while we have more bills we have 23
totals so and I think we've only got it
yeah so um representative Rumble I saw
you you had a question no
okay
all right so yeah we'll shoot for nine
but just check the calendar just to make
sure things don't change
anybody else
all right have a great week everybody
thank you